Hey guys, listen, I'm getting the sense that the listener really wants to get into the episode. Jump right in. You have anything you'd like to say before we get into the matter? Get it out now for ever. Hold your peace. We're about to jump in. I'm good.
嘿，伙计们，听着，我感觉听众真的很想进入正题。直接开始吧。在进入正题之前，你有什么想说的吗？现在就说出来，不然就永远别说了。保持安静。我们要开始了。我没问题。
I'm good. We're going to put your pot on. Let's jump into it. Put the shit out of this. Put the shit out of this. Here we go. Welcome to SmartList. Smart. Yeah, well let's jump into it. Let's get out of this. Yeah, let's party. Here we go. Welcome to SmartList.
我没问题。我们要开始录制了。让我们直接开始吧。把这该死的东西弄出来。把这该死的东西弄出来。我们开始吧。欢迎来到SmartList。Smart。好吧，让我们开始吧。让我们摆脱这个。是的，让我们狂欢吧。我们开始吧。欢迎来到SmartList。
SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. SmartList.
SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。
SmartList. SmartList. So, Sean was asking me before we came on, I decided to save it for- For the P-cast. Yeah, I was at the Emmys recently to present an award and didn't do the red carpet sort of sitting in the audience thing, just kind of drove there myself
SmartList。SmartList。所以，肖恩在我们开始之前问我，我决定把它留到——留到播客里说。是的，我最近去艾美奖颁奖，没有走红毯，也没有坐在观众席，只是自己开车去了。
and went through the back door, presented and then left right after that. So it was just, I said to Franny, Tracy, this is my 17 year old daughter. I said, I'm just gonna go, you know, in and out there, do you wanna come with me and kind of see what it was? I said, sure.
然后从后门进去，颁完奖就立刻离开了。所以我对弗兰妮说，特蕾西，这是我17岁的女儿。我说，我只是进去一下，出来一下，你想跟我一起去看看那是什么样吗？我说，当然。
So we drove down there together and we went in there. I said, and then we were in the green room and then there's- You take the limbic. I said, limbic was part of the route. And then, and then while we were, I said, come with me to the wings there, because they said it's time to present.
所以我们一起开车去了那里，然后进去了。我说，然后我们在休息室，然后有——你带了边缘系统。我说，边缘系统是路线的一部分。然后，当我们在一起的时候，我说，跟我去侧台，因为他们说该颁奖了。
And I said, Franny, come walk with me right to the edge of the stage. She goes, you can see how it all works. She walked over there. And the stage manager said to her, said, hey, you wanna walk the award out there? Yeah. And she's like, what do you mean?
我说，弗兰妮，跟我一起走到舞台边缘。她说，你可以看到这一切是如何运作的。她走过去。舞台监督对她说，嘿，你想把奖杯拿上去吗？是的。她说，你是什么意思？
Well, you know, instead of the awards gal walking it out there, the trophy gal, you do wanna walk the award out there? And she's like, sure. So Franny ended up walking out on stage with me, with the award in her hand and handed it to the winner there. And stole the show.
嗯，你知道，与其让颁奖小姐拿上去，那个奖杯小姐，你想把奖杯拿上去吗？她说，当然。所以弗兰妮最后和我一起走上舞台，手里拿着奖杯，把它交给了获奖者。抢尽了风头。
Cause she left gorgeous. She didn't steal the show, but you know, I mean, it was very cool that we were like on stage together at the Emmy, like when's that ever gonna happen? I know that's really cool. We were with your wife, Amanda. Yes, that is really cool. And Sean and I were, they were Scotty with some friends
因为她看起来太美了。她没有抢尽风头，但是，你知道，我的意思是，我们在艾美奖上一起站在舞台上真的很酷，这种事什么时候会发生呢？我知道，这真的很酷。我们和你妻子阿曼达在一起。是的，那真的很酷。肖恩和我，他们和一些朋友在一起。
and Amanda and I can, I think I can say it, Amanda and I are dating now. Wait, hang on. Yeah, we can say that. Yeah, you can say it, you don't have to follow that. No, but we said, I'd love it if you said it to me first privately. You walked out, you walked out with, and then you were there with Franny, we were like, oh my God you don't have to. No, but we said, I'd love it if you said it to me first, privately. You walked out, you walked out with,
阿曼达和我，我想我可以说了，阿曼达和我在约会。等等，等一下。是的，我们可以说。是的，你可以说，你不必跟着说。不，但我们说，如果你先私下告诉我，我会很高兴的。你走出来，你走出来，然后你和弗兰妮在那里，我们就像，哦天哪，你不必。不，但我们说，如果你先私下告诉我，我会很高兴的。你走出来，你走出来，
and then you were there with Franny, we were like, oh my God, it's Franny. And we were like rewinding to see, like we kept sort of rewinding. Yeah, I remember, yeah. You captured too great, but we looked at it. The camera didn't capture great enough, but it was so sweet.
然后你和弗兰妮在那里，我们就像，哦天哪，是弗兰妮。我们一直在倒带看，我们一直在倒带。是的，我记得，是的。你拍得太棒了，但我们看了。摄像机拍得不够好，但真的很甜。
We looked out into the crowd and there's Kimmel and Molly sitting right on the aisle. Like you could see the shot, they were like, oh my God, that's Franny. They like pulled out their iPhones and took some pictures for us. Isn't that sweet? But it was wild.
我们看向人群，基梅尔和莫莉坐在过道上。就像你能看到那个镜头，他们就像，哦天哪，那是弗兰妮。他们拿出iPhone拍了一些照片。那不是很甜吗？但这太疯狂了。
Right when you walked out to present, I looked over to your other beautiful, gorgeous, amazing daughter, Maple. And I looked at her and she was like, staring at the screen with a big smile on her face. She's like, she didn't have to say anything. I was like, what's going on in her head? Like, oh my God, that's my dad.
就在你走出来颁奖时，我看向你另一个漂亮、华丽、令人惊叹的女儿，梅普尔。我看着她，她盯着屏幕，脸上带着灿烂的笑容。她就像，她什么都不用说。我就想，她在想什么？就像，哦天哪，那是我爸爸。
So cool. So cute. I was like, what's going on in her head? Like, oh my God, that's my dad. So cool. So cute. It was really, really sweet. And I will say, MAPE has, I don't know what's happened. It's almost like since Christmas. And it's not been that long. Seemed so much older now. Yeah. Like in the last two weeks, I haven't seen her in two weeks before the other night. We bought her some growth hormone for Christmas. Oh, that's nice. How do you, how do you, how do you some growth hormone for Christmas. That's nice. How do you, how do you, how do you?
太酷了。太可爱了。我就想，她在想什么？就像，哦天哪，那是我爸爸。太酷了。太可爱了。这真的非常非常甜。我得说，梅普尔，我不知道发生了什么。几乎就像从圣诞节开始。没过多久。现在看起来大多了。是的。就像在过去两周里，前天晚上之前我两周没见她了。我们圣诞节给她买了一些生长激素。哦，那很好。你怎么，你怎么，你怎么买了一些生长激素作为圣诞礼物。那很好。你怎么，你怎么，你怎么？
It's a cream. It's a cream. I remember you saying you were like, we're going to take her to this Institute in the Alps. You guys went to Switzerland. Yeah. Well, you got to do it outside of the country. It's just too experimental right now.
那是乳霜。那是乳霜。我记得你说过，你说，我们要带她去阿尔卑斯山的这个研究所。你们去了瑞士。是的。嗯，你得在国外做。现在太实验性了。
But yeah, she's really growing. Four inches since Christmas. No, it's really sweet. She is. She's really great. I love her. All right, well, thank you for the family indulgence there Do you want to get to our guest or do you guys have I do I just want to Can I just ask you a quick quest? Yeah, Capricorn. Does that do it? Yeah, well part of it
但是的，她真的在长高。圣诞节以来长了四英寸。不，这真的很甜。她是。她真的很棒。我爱她。好吧，谢谢你们的家庭放纵。你们想见我们的嘉宾吗，还是你们有——我确实，我只是想，我能问你一个快速的问题吗？是的，摩羯座。那是真的吗？是的，嗯，部分是。
Do Capricorns where their headphones over their hoodie because that's what I want to know It's our chili in the house here, hold on. It's right. Oh, it's Shawn. Oh, look at that. There it is. By the way, Jason, your hair, so I will say this, the other thing I loved about, and I said it at the time when we were all watching,
摩羯座会把耳机戴在连帽衫外面吗？因为这就是我想知道的。这里有辣椒吗，等一下。是对的。哦，是肖恩。哦，看那个。就在那儿。顺便说一句，杰森，你的头发，所以我得说这个，我喜欢的另一件事，我在我们都在看的时候说了。
and Shawn, you can back me up. You came out, you presented, you did your little bit, you referenced the photo, it was the perfect, I was like, that's how you present. You were the absolute example. Honestly, it was so good, it was tight, I was like, that's how you present. You were the absolute example. Honestly, it was so good. It was tight, it was great. You look great with the long hair.
肖恩，你可以支持我。你出来了，你颁奖了，你做了你的小片段，你提到了那张照片，这太完美了，我就想，这就是你颁奖的方式。你是绝对的榜样。老实说，这太好了，很紧凑，我就想，这就是你颁奖的方式。你是绝对的榜样。老实说，这太好了。很紧凑，很棒。你留长发看起来很棒。
I think I told you that Lewis, who had saw you then, I knew Lewis like, out of the other days, has to be unsolicited. Jason's hair looks amazing. I was like, okay, man. Yeah, Lewis put his hands on me earlier. And then it was not. Old Lewis K.
我想我告诉过你，路易斯，当时看到你的人，我认识路易斯，就像，在其他日子里，必须是主动的。杰森的头发看起来太棒了。我就想，好吧，伙计。是的，路易斯早些时候把手放在我身上。然后那不是。老路易斯·K。
Yeah, I mean, like, come on, man. But you came out, you look great, and then you just did your bit, it was funny. And then you, I don't know, there was something really classy and simple. I know, I loved that. It was, it was great. You didn't try too hard, it was great.
是的，我的意思是，来吧，伙计。但你出来了，你看起来很棒，然后你只是做了你的片段，这很有趣。然后你，我不知道，有一些非常优雅和简单的事情。我知道，我喜欢那个。这很棒。你没有太努力，这很棒。
Not just cause you're my friend. This is one of the best parts though. Our, one of our friends that you, that we all know that we were sitting next to, they start playing the theme to the Will and Grace program. And she leans over to me and she goes, what song is this? She's a funny one. She's she going to comedy.
不仅仅是因为你是我的朋友。不过这是最好的部分之一。我们的，我们都认识的一位朋友，我们坐在她旁边，他们开始播放《威尔和格蕾丝》节目的主题曲。她向我靠过来，她说，这是什么歌？她是个有趣的人。她要去做喜剧。
I go, it's the theme to my show that I was on. Yeah. Listener, her name rhymes with Benifer Ganniston. But we're not gonna tell you. They're not gonna tell you. She goes, what song is that? I go, that's from my show. And she was like, you're an actor?
我说，这是我参加的节目的主题曲。是的。听众，她的名字和本尼弗·加尼斯顿押韵。但我们不会告诉你。他们不会告诉你。她说，那是什么歌？我说，那是我节目的。她就像，你是个演员？
I remember hearing her just faintly. You're an actor. I love how, you know, cause Franny and Maple have grown up with Jensen. They were little kids. They thought that she just sold, that she was a water salesman and a shampoo salesman until about five or six years ago.
我记得隐约听到她这么说。你是个演员。我喜欢，你知道，因为弗兰妮和梅普尔是和詹森一起长大的。她们还是小孩子的时候。她们以为她只是卖水的，是个洗发水推销员，直到五六年前。
They just didn't know. Just remember Nash came over for like in the before Christmas and he thought that Jen's house was a really nice restaurant. How do we always have this restaurant rented out? He's like, I like that restaurant. We can always get a table. It's not a restaurant, but. Guys, today I've got for you a big brain.
她们只是不知道。只记得纳什在圣诞节前过来，他以为詹的家是一家非常好的餐厅。我们怎么总是租下这家餐厅？他就像，我喜欢那家餐厅。我们总是能订到桌子。这不是餐厅，但是。伙计们，今天我为你们准备了一个大脑袋。
I know you like it when we have folks on the show that can fill us in on all the things we have trouble figuring out, people that can make us smarter, right? After all, it's called smart list. Well, we have a long way to go in that. We don't buy anything. Now, they might not be our most entertaining guests
我知道你们喜欢我们在节目中请到能为我们解答所有我们难以弄清楚的事情的人，能让我们变得更聪明的人，对吧？毕竟，它叫SmartList。嗯，我们还有很长的路要走。我们什么都不买。现在，他们可能不是我们最有趣的嘉宾。
or the funniest, but they are important to hear and sometimes you just have to take in the medicine. So today we've got just that person, so settle in, All right, so she's been studying human beings and society in general for decades. What? She's been sharing her findings with audiences all over the world. She delivers her lectures live or on podcasts or television and books. Often her lectures cover issues ranging from equality, religion, politics, relationships, and even procreation. For her work, she has been recognized with numerous awards and admiration, including a Peabody Award.
或者最搞笑的，但听听他们的话很重要，有时你只需要接受药物。所以今天我们请到了那个人，所以坐下来，好吧，所以她几十年来一直在研究人类和社会。什么？她一直在与世界各地的观众分享她的发现。她现场或在播客、电视和书籍中发表演讲。她的演讲经常涵盖从平等、宗教、政治、人际关系甚至生育等问题。因为她的工作，她获得了无数奖项和赞誉，包括皮博迪奖。
Lately, she has shocked the world to try to hand in the entertainment world too. She's found herself on the receiving end of one nomination from the Golden Globes, two from the Grammys, one from the Tonys, 13 Emmy nominations and ended up winning one of those. She has also hosted the Oscars. Guys, it's the girl with the lower back tattoo. It's America's own Amy Schumer. Oh, Amy Schumer. Guys, thought it was some academic stiff.
最近，她震惊了世界，试图在娱乐界也插上一手。她发现自己获得了金球奖的一项提名，格莱美奖的两项提名，托尼奖的一项提名，13项艾美奖提名，并最终赢得了其中一项。她还主持过奥斯卡颁奖典礼。伙计们，就是那个腰部下方有纹身的女孩。她是美国自己的艾米·舒默。哦，艾米·舒默。伙计们，还以为是什么学术书呆子。
Hi. Hi, Amy. Hi, guys. See you guys. Hi. Guys, I could just feel you see them going, oh, fucking Bateman's got himself another academic guy. I gotta say.
嗨。嗨，艾米。嗨，伙计们。见到你们。嗨。伙计们，我能感觉到你们在想，哦，该死的贝特曼又给自己找了个学术男。我得说。
You look so sad. That's his resting sad face. Can I just say I'm a little disappointed in Amy, because you were going to be my guest a long time ago. Yeah. And then Bateman stole you from out under. That's it. It often happens on the show. I actually just texted our producer the other day
你看上去真悲伤。那是他标志性的悲伤脸。我能说我有点对艾米失望吗，因为你很久以前就应该是我的嘉宾了。是的。然后贝特曼把你从我眼皮底下偷走了。就是这样。这在节目中经常发生。我其实前几天刚给我们的制片人发了短信。
a couple of names and he's like, in process. And I was like, oh, okay, somebody else got. Can I just say this is my first, actual first time that two men have ever fought over me and I just want to relish it for just a second. Really? Yeah. Okay, two and a half. Two and a half.
几个名字，他说，正在处理中。我就想，哦，好吧，别人得到了。我能说这是我第一次，真正第一次有两个男人为我争吵，我只想享受这一刻。真的吗？是的。好吧，两个半。两个半。
I'm a half. Amy, I'm such a huge fan. I've never met you before. I've always felt like, God, I just love you. I just love you. I just met you right now. I've never met you. What is your problem?
我是半个。艾米，我是你的超级粉丝。我以前从没见过你。我一直觉得，天哪，我就是爱你。我就是爱你。我刚才才见到你。我以前从没见过你。你有什么问题？
What's your problem? Nothing. I can hear all of you. I'm walking in front of you. I'm thrilled to be here to promote my lectures. My lectures. Oh, I thought you were going to write it to a plug for your new here to promote my lectures. My lectures. Oh, I thought you were going to write it to a plug for your new project.
你有什么问题？没什么。我能听到你们所有人。我走在你们前面。我很高兴来到这里宣传我的讲座。我的讲座。哦，我以为你要为你的新项目做广告。
Oh my gosh. No, I'm done. Did I tell you? I just left the business, so. You're doing, we're making news. This is it, yeah. What are you gonna do? I'm just gonna be like a fit model, I guess.
哦，天哪。不，我做完了。我告诉过你吗？我刚离开这个行业，所以。你在做，我们在制造新闻。就是这样，是的。你要做什么？我想我大概会成为一个试衣模特。
You might as well. Hello? You, no, no, we're still here. Oh, okay. What about, explain that incredibly gorgeous background you've got there. Now, look at that. Is that a house?
你最好这样做。喂？你，不，不，我们还在。哦，好吧。关于，解释一下你身后那个极其华丽的背景。现在，看看那个。那是一个房子吗？
This is honestly my first time anybody's ever like, seen the back of my thing, you would think, but. I'd say that better. You got another chance to say that. Okay, okay. Still rolling. I haven't podcasted from this room ever. Oh, you're not.
老实说，这是第一次有人看到我东西的后面，你会认为，但是。我说得更好。你有另一个机会说那个。好吧，好吧。还在录。我从来没有在这个房间里录过播客。哦，你没有。
So this is my first exposure and I didn't think it through. And this is my office. This is my office. That looks real tasteful. Yeah, it's not good. It's not good. No, it's good.
所以这是我的第一次曝光，我没有考虑周全。这是我的办公室。这是我的办公室。看起来很有品位。是的，不好。不好。不，很好。
Is it a home office? Are we talking to you from a home office? Yes, this is my home office according to my taxes. And... Sorry, I don't wanna get you in trouble with the IRS. But no. office according to my taxes. And... Sorry, I don't wanna get you in trouble with the IRS. But now? That's not my goal. Yeah, no, this is my little home office.
这是家庭办公室吗？我们是在家庭办公室和你说话吗？是的，根据我的税单，这是我的家庭办公室。而且……抱歉，我不想让你惹上国税局的麻烦。但是不。根据我的税单。而且……抱歉，我不想让你惹上国税局的麻烦。但是现在？那不是我的目标。是的，不，这是我的小家庭办公室。
It's not big, but it's mine. And as you can see, I started color coding my books and then I stopped. Yeah, I get it. It's exhausting about it. My book, I'm sorry. Sean color coded his books, right? And it took like better part of 15 seconds.
它不大，但它是我的。如你所见，我开始按颜色对我的书进行分类，然后我停下来了。是的，我明白了。这很累人。我的书，抱歉。肖恩按颜色分类了他的书，对吧？花了大概15秒钟。
Yeah, well it's not worse than my book. Well, audio books are, you know, they're tough. But a lot of people have home offices. Do you actually sit there and work from your home office? I haven't much. That's why, I mean, this is truly my first podcast from here. How's it feel? So I feel exposed, I feel humiliated.
是的，嗯，这不比我的书差。嗯，有声读物，你知道，它们很难。但很多人有家庭办公室。你真的坐在那里在你的家庭办公室工作吗？我没怎么坐过。这就是为什么，我的意思是，这确实是我在这里录的第一个播客。感觉如何？所以我感到暴露，我感到羞辱。
I just, I'm realizing I left this door open and you can see a sad pile of stuffed animals. No, I can see your tasteful windows and couch and rugs and like, Amy's stuffed animals. I will say that Amy, that pile of stuffed animals, it does look like it's from a horror film. I will just say. If you saw these things up close, you would really question the rest of this interview. It's really, really terrifying. Should I grab them? I mean, and I wanted to say of all regrets,
我只是，我意识到我把这扇门开着，你可以看到一堆悲伤的毛绒玩具。不，我可以看到你很有品位的窗户、沙发和地毯，还有，艾米的毛绒玩具。我得说，艾米，那堆毛绒玩具，看起来确实像是恐怖电影里的。我只想说。如果你近距离看到这些东西，你真的会质疑这次采访的其余部分。它真的，真的太可怕了。我应该拿走它们吗？我的意思是，我想说所有的遗憾中，
which is of course doing this podcast at all, but mostly not wearing a bra. Okay. And I'm, so I'm gonna just kind of. I've got one on. Okay, good.'m, so I'm gonna just kind of. Find me. I've got one on. Okay, good. Now, Amy, what about working from home? What does work look like for you?
当然是做这个播客，但主要是没穿胸罩。好吧。而且我，所以我只是要……我穿了一个。好吧，很好。找到我。我穿了一个。好吧，很好。现在，艾米，关于在家工作呢？工作对你来说是什么样子的？
And I'm not being a shitty. How does a stand up, or, well, you're beyond that. You're more than that. But when you're doing stand up work, this is the part that interests me. You're not just walking around town with a little pad of paper and like jotting down shit you think might be funny, right?
我不是在说废话。单口喜剧演员，或者，嗯，你超越了那个。你不仅仅是那样。但当你做单口喜剧工作时，这是我感兴趣的部分。你不是只是带着一个小记事本在城里走来走去，记下你认为可能很有趣的东西，对吧？
It's harder than that. You're sitting down, you're trying to craft actual, you know, word sequencing on a joke set up, but like, does that happen in an office for you staring at a wall or is it more collaborative? I don't do, I don't really write. I think I used to write. I now just will say something to a friend
这比那更难。你坐下来，你试图精心制作实际的，你知道，笑话设置中的词序，但是，这在你的办公室里发生吗，盯着墙看，还是更具协作性？我不做，我真的不写。我想我过去常写。我现在只是会对朋友说些什么。
or my husband or my son. I'll go, is that funny? And then I write it down. And then I, yeah, I've never had the discipline to sit and write. I sit and write scripts in bed. Like I sit up in bed and I mostly write in bed. I don't know what I'm doing in here.
或者我的丈夫或我的儿子。我会说，那有趣吗？然后我把它写下来。然后我，是的，我从来没有纪律坐下来写。我坐在床上写剧本。就像我坐在床上，我大部分时间都在床上写。我不知道我在这里做什么。
I don't feel comfortable in here and thank you for pointing that out. But you're not, When you say in here, do you mean this planet or are you talking about your audience? But when you're up on stage, you're not riffing off of the points, are you? No, no, that's from like, you know, try,
我不觉得在这里舒服，谢谢你指出来。但你不是，当你在这里说时，你是说这个星球，还是你在说你的观众？但当你站在舞台上时，你不是在即兴发挥，对吧？不，不，那是来自，你知道，尝试，
I'll have a premise and I'll kind of just say the premise on stage at the comedy cellar or something and then just work it out and you know, yeah. So let me ask you about that about the comedy cellar and all that kind of stuff. So for you now, you're an established comedy star, but you'd still have to do You still go and you work stuff out. I mean just talk to tell you know Tracy what that process is like for you. Tracy's Sean sister.
我会有一个前提，我会有点只是在喜剧地窖或其他地方在舞台上说出这个前提，然后把它解决出来，你知道，是的。所以让我问你关于那个，关于喜剧地窖和所有那种东西。所以对你现在来说，你是一个成熟的喜剧明星，但你仍然必须做，你仍然去，你解决问题。我的意思是只是告诉，你知道，特蕾西那个过程对你来说是什么样的。特蕾西是肖恩的妹妹。
Tracy Morgan. Tracy Morgan. Okay. He's a listener. Cause he's not doing that. But what do you, what is that like for you? So you're talking to your husband,
特蕾西·摩根。特蕾西·摩根。好吧。他是个听众。因为他没在做那个。但你，那对你来说是什么样的？所以你在和你的丈夫说话，
your friends or whatever, and then you end up having some material. You're like, all right, I've got like a bunch of stuff. And then you go, what? You're like, it's a Thursday night. Like tonight you go like, I'm gonna put the kids to bed
你的朋友或什么的，然后你最终有了一些素材。你就像，好吧，我有一些东西。然后你走，什么？你就像，这是一个周四晚上。就像今晚你走，就像我要把孩子们哄上床。
and I'm gonna go to the comedy cellar at 10 o'clock and just show them. I only have one kid, but you're one of my best friends. One kid, sorry. So you know that. I know, I mean, I say kids, because I'm trying to shame you. Do you,
我要在10点去喜剧地窖，只是给他们看。我只有一个孩子，但你是我的好朋友之一。一个孩子，抱歉。所以你知道那个。我知道，我的意思是，我说孩子们，因为我想羞辱你。你，
Because I know you've been trying. Do you, Actually, I have. No, but totally have, which makes it real big, and that's what makes it funnier. But do you, do you think? Wait, actually, wait, can I show you something? Cause Jason asked me one time like very rudely about,
因为我知道你一直在尝试。你，其实，我有。不，但完全有，这让它变得很大，这就是让它变得更有趣的原因。但你，你认为？等等，其实，等等，我能给你看个东西吗？因为杰森有一次非常粗鲁地问我关于，
cause I actually had my uterus removed and- Is that true? And he was like, did you save it? And I was like, I actually did save it. I like had it bronzed, you know, because of how difficult my pregnancy was. And I can't believe I, I didn't even think of this, but I get the chance to show this to you.
因为我实际上切除了我的子宫，而且——那是真的吗？他就像，你留着它了吗？我就像，我确实留着它了。我把它做成了青铜色，你知道，因为我的怀孕过程有多困难。我不敢相信我，我甚至没想过这个，但我有机会把它展示给你。
No way. It's pretty good. It's not my sun whites on my pants when I get up. Okay. This is my uterus. Oh, really? My God. Oh my God.
没门。这太好了。当我站起来时，它不是我裤子上的太阳白。好吧。这是我的子宫。哦，真的吗？天哪。天哪。
Can you hold it closer to the camera? That's crazy. Wow. Okay. So I take my joke back. I take my joke back because I literally had zero idea. I thought I wanted to do it. No, it's fine.
你能把它拿得离摄像机近一点吗？那太疯狂了。哇。好吧。所以我收回我的笑话。我收回我的笑话，因为我真的完全不知道。我以为我想做它。不，没关系。
It's fine. Time's up. Honestly, time's up for you. Well, no, I'm I was gonna- No, it's fine. It's fine. Time's up. Honestly, time's up for you. Well, no, obviously- Check your email, Will. Yeah. You're done. How are you tweeting?
没关系。时间到了。老实说，你的时间到了。嗯，不，我本来要——不，没关系。没关系。时间到了。老实说，你的时间到了。嗯，不，显然——检查你的电子邮件，威尔。是的。你完了。你怎么在发推特？
I didn't even see you leave the screen. How are you? I am, I do apologize. I had zero idea, obviously, but- It's all good. What I wanna know is, so you write down your joke ideas. It's a Thursday night,
我甚至没看到你离开屏幕。你怎么了？我，我确实道歉。我显然完全不知道，但是——没关系。我想知道的是，所以你写下你的笑话点子。这是一个周四晚上，
you put your son to bed, and then you go, honey, I'm gonna go to the Comedy Central at 10 p.m. I'm just gonna walk over there or you show up or how does that work? Like how do you go and just work stuff out? So I would usually, I really haven't been, I've been doing other stuff, but I would, I would,
你把你的儿子哄上床，然后你走，亲爱的，我要在晚上10点去喜剧中心。我只是要走过去，或者你出现，或者那是怎么运作的？就像你怎么去解决问题？所以我通常会，我真的没怎么去，我一直在做别的事情，但我会，我会，
yeah, I would say like, I would actually say, I'm gonna do a like surprise show at the seller and I would go and do like, you know, however much time I have 45 minutes or something and just try new stuff and it's like I do like day shows so the audience doesn't feel too bad It's like 4 p.m. They pay like five. That's a great idea. Yeah, it's a great idea And it's like Seriously, you know you have a comedians like Joan Rivers or Rickles and they would be doing like some casino show at like 11 a.m. And you're like, and now that's like me.
是的，我会说，就像，我实际上会说，我要在卖方做一个惊喜秀，我会去，你知道，我有多少时间45分钟或什么的，只是尝试新东西，就像我做日间秀，所以观众不会感觉太糟糕。就像下午4点。他们付大概五块钱。那是个好主意。是的，那是个好主意。而且就像，说真的，你知道你有像琼·里弗斯或里克斯那样的喜剧演员，他们会在上午11点做一些赌场秀。你就像，现在那就像我。
Yeah, that's like my dream is just to give up. Yeah, that's perfect. Because everybody wants to be. This seems stupid, but like you call them in advance and go, hey, take me to Shimmer, I'm showing up at 4 p.m. And I'm gonna do an hour or no, you just show up. Well, no, I just like text Liz, the manager, SD the booker and I say,
是的，那就像我的梦想，只是放弃。是的，那很完美。因为每个人都想成为。这看起来很蠢，但就像你提前给他们打电话说，嘿，带我去舒默，我下午4点出现。我要做一个小时，还是不，你只是出现。嗯，不，我只是像给利兹发短信，经理，SD预订员，我说，
it's today a good day for me to come and do. And they would write like secret girl show and Liz would post a picture of her pug and that really means it's me and some people know that. So like, you know, 60 people would come at, you know, four PM on a Tuesday. I'd be right there. I can't imagine.
今天是来做的好日子吗？他们会写像秘密女孩秀，利兹会贴一张她的哈巴狗的照片，那真的意味着是我，有些人知道那个。所以就像，你知道，60个人会在，你知道，周二下午四点来。我就在那里。我无法想象。
Lunchtime comedy. Look after that pug. Yeah, but that's how you know. And then I work it out and I take out the stuff that's bombing like everything on this podcast so far. No, no, no, it's fine. What about, what about? I'm just vulnerable.
午餐时间喜剧。照顾好那只哈巴狗。是的，但这就是你知道的方式。然后我把它解决出来，我把那些像这个播客上到目前为止的一切一样炸掉的东西拿出来。不，不，不，没关系。关于，关于？我只是很脆弱。
Whoa, whoa. You just shut the fuck up. Squeeze me. Will, your son, Will mentioned your son reminded me of, okay, so guys. I have a daughter. No, her son, Will mentioned your son, it reminded me of, okay, so guys. I have a daughter. No, her son's name is Jean. Oh, come on. And she named his middle name Attel, right?
哇，哇。你刚才闭嘴。挤我。威尔，你的儿子，威尔提到了你的儿子提醒了我，好吧，所以伙计们。我有一个女儿。不，她的儿子，威尔提到了你的儿子，它提醒了我，好吧，所以伙计们。我有一个女儿。不，她儿子的名字是吉恩。哦，得了吧。她给他的中间名取名为阿特尔，对吧？
After David Attel. And then she realized, well, say the first and middle name quickly together. Sean, go ahead. Jean Attel. Yeah. Jean-Ata. Yeah. Jean-Ata. So she changed it because she thought it might sound
以大卫·阿特尔命名。然后她意识到，嗯，快速把名字和中间名放在一起说。肖恩，继续。吉恩·阿特尔。是的。吉恩-阿塔。是的。吉恩-阿塔。所以她改了它，因为她认为它听起来可能
like genital. See, she, Sean didn't put it together like me as a new mom until it was a month in. And then I realized, and my husband's last name was Fisher, so I named him Genital Fisher. Genital Fisher. Like that, to be funny. So she did a little switcheroo on that.
像生殖器。看，她，肖恩不像我作为一个新妈妈那样把它放在一起，直到一个月后。然后我意识到，我丈夫的姓是费舍尔，所以我给他取名为生殖器·费舍尔。生殖器·费舍尔。就像那样，为了有趣。所以她在那上面做了一个小小的切换。
We had the same thing with Maple. We, Maple Sylvie Bateman. And she, and one of her friends, older sisters said, wait, Maple Sir at Bacon? And we're like, oh shit, we gotta go downtown and we gotta change that. Is that the same as Amy your kid after like, cock and balls?
我们在梅普尔身上也有同样的情况。我们，梅普尔·西尔维·贝特曼。她，她的一个朋友，姐姐说，等等，梅普尔·瑟·培根？我们就像，哦该死，我们得去市中心，我们得改掉那个。这和艾米你的孩子像，鸡巴和蛋蛋一样吗？
Yeah, well, what about that? What about Amy? What about his middle name, Nattay? That would have been perfect. It would have been fun. We changed it to David. We played it safe. He sounds like a lawyer.
是的，嗯，那个怎么样？关于艾米？关于他的中间名，纳泰？那本来会很完美。那本来会很有趣。我们把它改成了大卫。我们安全起见。他听起来像个律师。
Smart. Yeah. All right, now Amy. Yes. What was your first introduction to stand up? Why did you get started in that world? Is mom or dad funny? Did they take you to comedy shops?
聪明。是的。好吧，现在艾米。是的。你第一次接触单口喜剧是什么时候？你为什么开始进入那个世界？妈妈或爸爸有趣吗？他们带你去喜剧店吗？
Like, why that? What happened? Actually, we did watch a lot of comedy. I grew up watching you, just kidding. Don't you hate when people say that? Cause I'm like your age. Okay. I just remember being like one years old
就像，为什么是那个？发生了什么？其实，我们确实看了很多喜剧。我是在看你长大的，开个玩笑。你不讨厌人们那样说吗？因为我像你这么大。好吧。我只记得我像一岁的时候
watching you in your prime. I just remember being like one years old watching you in your prime. I loved Gilda and Lucy and Whoopi Goldberg and Comic Relief and SNL, which wasn't branded SNL then. But you know, and then, and I did plays and yeah, my parents were both really funny. But then I did improv after college. Were they show, were your parents in entertainment?
看着你在你的黄金时期。我只记得我像一岁的时候看着你在你的黄金时期。我喜欢吉尔达、露西、乌比·戈德堡、喜剧救济和SNL，当时还没被命名为SNL。但是你知道，然后，我演了戏，是的，我父母都很有趣。但后来我在大学后做了即兴表演。他们是表演，你父母是从事娱乐业的吗？
No, my mom's a speech and hearing therapist for the deaf and my dad sold baby furniture. Really? Yeah, yeah. Did he make the baby furniture? No, he just, he imported it from Europe, from Italy. So parents who wanted fancy baby furniture for some reason. The furniture, not the babies.
不，我妈妈是聋哑人的言语和听力治疗师，我爸爸卖婴儿家具。真的吗？是的，是的。他做婴儿家具吗？不，他只是，他从欧洲，从意大利进口。所以想要花哨婴儿家具的父母出于某种原因。家具，不是婴儿。
Yeah, we did not import the babies. Yeah. And we will be right back. Thank you to Viori for supporting the show. Hey guys, if you're sick and tired of rock and the same old workout gear, Viori has you covered. They've got a new perspective on performance apparel. Here's the thing.
是的，我们没有进口婴儿。是的。我们马上回来。感谢Viori支持这个节目。嘿伙计们，如果你厌倦了穿着同样的旧健身装备，Viori为你提供了保障。他们对性能服装有新的视角。事情是这样的。
Everything is designed to work out in, but doesn't look or feel like it. It's so comfortable you want to wear it all the time. The good news is you can. Their gear looks great every day, whether you're at the gym or going out to dinner. I'm a sweatpants guy. I like to feel comfortable 24 hours a day. So I'm kind of a Sunday performance jogger guy. I wear them all the time,
一切都是为了锻炼而设计的，但看起来或感觉起来不像。它太舒服了，你想一直穿着它。好消息是你确实可以。他们的装备每天看起来都很棒，无论是在健身房还是出去吃晚餐。我是个运动裤男。我喜欢24小时都感觉舒服。所以我有点像周日性能慢跑裤男。我一直穿着它们，
where I'm around the house, I wear them to go out, I wear them to the store, I wear them all the time. Viori is an investment in your happiness and they're hooking up smart list listeners with 20% off your first purchase at Viori.com slash smart list.
我在房子周围，我穿着它们出去，我穿着它们去商店，我一直穿着它们。Viori是对你幸福的一项投资，他们正在为SmartList听众提供在Viori.com斜杠smartlist首次购买20%的折扣。
That's a V-U-O-R-I dot com slash smart list. Not only will you receive 20% off your first purchase, but you'll also enjoy free shipping on any US orders over $75 in free returns. Go to veori.com slash smartlist and discover the versatility of veori clothing. Smartlist is brought to you in part by ShipStation. Whether you're shipping 100 packages or thousands a month,
那是V-U-O-R-I点com斜杠smartlist。你不仅会收到首次购买20%的折扣，而且你还会享受任何超过75美元的美国订单的免费送货和免费退货。去veori.com斜杠smartlist，发现veori服装的多功能性。Smartlist由ShipStation部分赞助。无论你是每月运送100个包裹还是数千个，
ShipStation can help optimize how you ship so you can stay competitive while you scale up. Their effortless integration is everywhere you sell online, including Amazon, Walmart, Shopify, and more. In one simple dashboard, you can manage orders, print labels, compare rates, optimize every shipment, and automate delivery notifications. Here's the kicker.
ShipStation可以帮助优化你的运输方式，这样你就可以在扩大规模的同时保持竞争力。他们轻松的集成在你在线销售的任何地方，包括亚马逊、沃尔玛、Shopify等。在一个简单的仪表板中，你可以管理订单、打印标签、比较费率、优化每次运输并自动化交付通知。关键在于。
ShipStation has enterprise solutions that reduce warehouse costs and improve profitability. So as your business grows, you can save thousands on shipping costs. It's pretty clear why 98% of companies that stick with ShipStation for a year become customers for life. Optimize and keep up your momentum for growth with ShipStation. Use promo code smartless today at ShipStation.com to sign up for your free 60-day trial at ShipStation.com promo code smartless. Smartless is supported by Liquid IV. You know what I started doing recently?
ShipStation有减少仓库成本和提高盈利能力的解决方案。所以随着你的业务增长，你可以节省数千美元的运输成本。很明显，为什么98%坚持使用ShipStation一年的公司成为了终身客户。用ShipStation优化并保持你的增长势头。今天在ShipStation.com使用促销代码smartless注册你的免费60天试用，ShipStation.com促销代码smartless。Smartless由Liquid IV支持。你知道我最近开始做什么了吗？
I started drinking my drinks through a straw, even if it's milk or water or a soft drink or water with Liquid IV in it. I don't know, it makes me feel, I can feel it going in my body and it feels real good when I sip it through a straw. And liquid IV I know is making me hydrated fast when I sip through a straw. So I don't know, maybe it's just me, but whether you hydrate to live or live to hydrate, liquid IV quenches your thirst faster than water alone, with three times the electrolytes of the leading
我开始用吸管喝饮料，即使是牛奶或水或软饮料或加了Liquid IV的水。我不知道，它让我感觉，我能感觉到它进入我的身体，当我用吸管啜饮时感觉真的很好。而且我知道当我用吸管啜饮时，Liquid IV让我快速补水。所以我不知道，也许只是我，但无论你是为了生活而补水还是为了补水而生活，Liquid IV比单独的水更快地解渴，电解质是领先者的三倍
sports drink, plus eight vitamins and nutrients for everyday wellness. All you need to do is snag your favorite sugar-free stick and 16 ounces of water, and you're on your way to hydration. I've made it a habit to make the first thing I do every single day, drink eight ounces of water, every single day, and I've added liquid IV into it,
运动饮料，加上八种维生素和营养素，用于日常健康。你所需要做的就是拿走你最喜欢的无糖棒和16盎司的水，你就走上了补水之路。我已经养成了一个习惯，每天做的第一件事就是喝八盎司的水，每天，我还在里面加了Liquid IV，
so now I can feel good about hydrating right when I get out of bed every single day. And I've added Liquid IV into it. So now I can feel good about hydrating right when I get out of bed every single morning. However you hydrate, grab your Liquid IV hydration multiplier sugar-free in bulk nationwide at Costco, or get 20% off your first order when you go to liquidiv.com and use code smartLIS at checkout. That's 20% off your first order
所以我现在可以感觉很好，每天早上起床时就补水。而且我还在里面加了Liquid IV。所以现在我每天早上起床时就可以感觉很好地补水。无论你如何补水，在Costco全国批量购买你的Liquid IV补水倍增器无糖，或者当你去liquidiv.com并使用代码smartLIS结账时，首次订单可享受20%的折扣。那是首次订单20%的折扣
when you shop Better Hydration today using promo code smartLIS at checkout. That's 20% off your first order when you shop Better Hydration today using promo code smartLIS at liquidiv.com. And now back to the show. What was that first time, Amy, that first time you were on stage? I just, I'm asking just because I've never had the balls to do any sort of stand up or monologue type of thing. I mean, I did once with Willie at UCB,
当你今天购物更好的补水时，使用促销代码smartLIS结账。那是首次订单20%的折扣，当你今天在liquidiv.com购物更好的补水时，使用促销代码smartLIS。现在回到节目。艾米，你第一次站在舞台上是什么时候？我只是，我问是因为我从来没有胆量做任何单口喜剧或独白类型的事情。我的意思是，我和威利在UCB做过一次，
but it was, I have total blackout because I was so nervous, but I can't imagine. He can't even do a toast. Come on. Is this true? He can't do a toast. I really lock up. That's so funny.
但它是，我完全断片了，因为我太紧张了，但我无法想象。他甚至不能做祝酒词。得了吧。这是真的吗？他不能做祝酒词。我真的锁住了。那太有趣了。
When you're on stage there, the first time you decided to, okay, I'm gonna do this set or this series of jokes I think are funny, what was that like and how old were you? I was 23, which means I've been doing stand-up for 20 years. No, I'm 42, never mind. And where were you? Where was it? Was it like at college?
当你在舞台上时，你第一次决定，好吧，我要做这套或这系列我认为有趣的笑话，那是什么样的，你多大了？我23岁，这意味着我做单口喜剧20年了。不，我42岁，没关系。你在哪里？在哪里？是在大学吗？
It was at Gotham, the old Gotham comedy club. I had done, and I was like, I did one of those improv groups that you like pay to be in, like just a straight up hustle from backstage, you know, the paper. And yeah, it was like, you know, $50 to like go to a freezing theater and meet like other mentally ill people. And one of the women in it was like, I'm doing a show, I mean, you just had to bring four people.
是在哥谭，老哥谭喜剧俱乐部。我做过，我就像，我做了那些你付钱参加的即兴表演小组之一，就像直接从后台的喧嚣，你知道，纸。而且是的，它就像，你知道，50美元去一个冰冷的剧院，见像其他精神病患者。其中一个女人就像，我在做一个节目，我的意思是，你只需要带四个人。
And I watched her and I just thought like, I could maybe do this. That's how you get up on stage is if you brought four people to pick up. It's still like that, yeah. Really? So it's like amateur night, but you gotta have four people to, okay.
我看着她，我只是想，我大概能做这个。这就是你如何走上舞台，如果你带了四个人去接。仍然是那样，是的。真的吗？所以它就像业余之夜，但你必须有四个人去，好吧。
Yes, you can get, you can actually get in front of real audience, it's not amateur night, but you gotta have four people to, okay. Yes, you can get, you can actually get in front of real audience. It's not just like right to open mics because, you know, and generally a real audience will laugh at some point because they feel bad for you. Did you trust that the stuff that you worked on was working? I mean.
是的，你可以，你实际上可以站在真正的观众面前，这不是业余之夜，但你必须有四个人去，好吧。是的，你可以，你实际上可以站在真正的观众面前。不仅仅是直接去开放麦，因为，你知道，通常真正的观众会在某个时候笑，因为他们为你感到难过。你相信你所做的事情在起作用吗？我的意思是。
No, I decided that day that I was gonna do it. Wow. And I- She had no material. No, I wrote out a set, like I just came up with like, what would, you know- Fuck me, what was your first joke? This is fascinating.
不，我那天决定我要做它。哇。而且我——她没有素材。不，我写了一套，就像我只是想出像，什么会，你知道——去你的，你的第一个笑话是什么？这太迷人了。
It was about how skywriting is a stupid way to get engaged, cause it- You know, it gets so sad, it's like, I had, and I talked about taking the crosstown bus in Manhattan and like, it's so sad, it's like I had, and I talked about taking the Crosstown bus in Manhattan and like it was just like. You trusted your ability to just kind of riff on stuff and that there would be a shared sort of experience with something like that.
它是关于空中写字是一种愚蠢的订婚方式，因为它——你知道，它变得如此悲伤，就像，我有，我谈到了在曼哈顿乘坐横穿城镇的公共汽车，就像，它太悲伤了，就像我有，我谈到了在曼哈顿乘坐横穿城镇的公共汽车，就像它只是像。你相信你有能力只是即兴发挥，并且会有某种共同的体验。
Yeah, and it went well enough. I think this is a lot of comedians experience that your first time you do really well and then the second time you die on stage. Yeah. What if it hadn't gone well? Do you think you would have said, okay, screw this, and if so, where do you think you would have gone career wise?
是的，而且它进行得足够好。我想这是很多喜剧演员的经历，你第一次做得很好，然后第二次你在舞台上死掉了。是的。如果它进行得不好呢？你认为你会说，去你的，如果是这样，你认为你在职业生涯中会去哪里？
What are you drawn to? My gosh, I was always gonna just perform. Like I never had a thing. Like I went to college for theater and had no goals, had no backup. I waited in tables and bartended for a long time. I get that. But you can see that, right?
你被什么吸引？天哪，我总是要表演。就像我从来没有一件事。就像我上大学学戏剧，没有目标，没有后备。我等了很长时间的桌子和当酒保。我明白了。但你可以看到那个，对吧？
Me being like a rude waitress. Do you miss theater? I got to do a Broadway show. Oh, what'd you do? I did a Steve Martin play called Meteor Shower. Oh, yeah. Oh, much on the week. Yeah.
我像一个粗鲁的女服务员。你怀念戏剧吗？我得做一个百老汇节目。哦，你做了什么？我做了一个史蒂夫·马丁的戏叫《流星雨》。哦，是的。哦，很多在周。是的。
Is that what you got the Tony nomination for? Yes. Yes. Wow. That's so cool, Amy. Oh, Sean's wig. Yeah. Is that the Tony nomination for? Yes. Yes. That's so cool, Amy. Thank you. I've seen now twice prayer for the French Republic on Broadway. It's so good. You guys have to see it.
那是你获得托尼奖提名的原因吗？是的。是的。哇。那太酷了，艾米。哦，肖恩的假发。是的。那是托尼奖提名的原因吗？是的。是的。那太酷了，艾米。谢谢。我现在看过两次百老汇的《为法兰西共和国祈祷》。太好了。你们必须去看。
Oh, yeah. I've heard that's great. Yeah. I used to wait tables and my one joke was I would bring the food to the—I was a runner. I was in a waiter. I ran the food to the people. Oh, the story's falling apart already. Anytime I would have to play Anytime I would have to play.
哦，是的。我听说那很棒。是的，我过去常等桌子，我的一个笑话是我会把食物带到——我是一个跑腿的。我是一个服务员。我把食物送到人们那里。哦，故事已经分崩离析了。任何时候我必须玩，任何时候我必须玩。
I would have to play. You just come in hissing, hot shit, hot shit, hot shit. I would come in and right before I put the food down, somebody would inevitably say, oh, that looks fantastic. And I'd point to my shirt and I'd go, thanks, I just got it. Come on. Yeah, I just got it. And I'm like, okay.
我必须玩。你只是进来嘶嘶作响，热屎，热屎，热屎。我会进来，就在我放下食物之前，有人不可避免地会说，哦，那看起来太棒了。我会指着我的衬衫说，谢谢，我刚得到的。得了吧。是的，我刚得到的。我就像，好吧。
Come on. Yeah, I worked every time. Oh, my gosh. You get any repeat customers who are like, you fucking, you did that like the last three times. Sean, I- It's the fucking sweatiest joke. Please fucking stop.
得了吧。是的，每次都有效。哦，天哪。你有没有得到任何重复的顾客，他们就像，你该死的，你像过去三次那样做了。肖恩，我——这是该死的最出汗的笑话。请该死的停止。
I feel like I didn't gush to you, Sean, for how funny and how much I love you. But that's okay. My jokes that I do at nauseam, and I cannot stop myself, is whenever somebody, I'll order a drink, a cocktail, and when the waiter rings it over, I go, who sent this?
我觉得我没有对你涌出，肖恩，因为你有多有趣以及我有多爱你。但没关系。我做的那些令人作呕的笑话，我无法停止自己，是每当有人，我会点一杯饮料，鸡尾酒，当服务员把它拿过来时，我说，谁送的？
I do it all the time. Damn it, okay, that's it, okay. I do it when he'll drink. Who sent this? What, like a bar restaurant anywhere? I do that all the time. Sean also does something that never doesn't work. He'll grab whatever clutch or purse he sees around
我经常这么做。该死，好吧，就这样，好吧。他喝酒的时候我也会这么做。这是谁发的？什么，就像随便哪家酒吧餐厅？我经常那样做。肖恩也会做一些永远不会失败的事情。他会随手抓起他看到的任何手拿包或钱包，
and he'll throw it over his shoulder and distractedly kind of look up from rifling through and going, guys, does anybody need anything from CVS? Right back. Or anytime there's a candle, he holds it up and then guards the flame and goes, guys, right this way, I think. Yeah, does anybody know the bathroom?
然后把它甩在肩上，心不在焉地从里面翻找，一边抬头说，伙计们，有人需要从CVS买什么吗？马上回来。或者每当有蜡烛的时候，他就会把它举起来，护住火苗说，伙计们，这边请，我想。是的，有人知道洗手间在哪吗？
Another, a favorite one that we do, a lot of comics I'm friends with, we'll just like, this is probably another bit everyone does, but we try to, we all act like we're gonna pay the bill. We go like, no, no, I got this, and then we'll put like a Metro card or like just something that makes no sense, you know? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
另一个我们常做的，我很多喜剧演员朋友也常做的，这可能也是每个人都会做的段子，但我们试着，我们都假装我们要去买单。我们会说，不，不，我来付，然后我们会拿出像地铁卡或者其他完全没意义的东西，你知道吗？是啊，是啊，是啊。
Yeah, or our favorite, this is my favorite bit we would do is we would go, maybe you've heard this too. I don't know if this is like a bit, but it's like comic school, like, oh, my God, did you guys see me last night? Like I was I was amazing. Have you heard this before? Yeah, I was amazing.
是啊，或者我们最喜欢的，这是我最喜欢的段子，我们会说，也许你也听过这个。我不知道这算不算个段子，但这就像喜剧学校里的，哦，天哪，你们昨晚看我表演了吗？我简直太棒了。你以前听过这个吗？是啊，我太棒了。
Like I don't know what happened. Everything was just firing. And then one of us would go like Keith. We were there and they goes, well, they were mostly from out of town. Yeah. Yeah. They were barked in, they didn't know where they were. Sean, did we already talk about this in the past?
就像我不知道发生了什么。一切都恰到好处。然后我们其中一个人会像基思那样说。我们在那儿，他们说，好吧，他们大多是外地人。是啊。是啊。他们是被拉客进来的，他们不知道自己在哪里。肖恩，我们过去谈过这个吗？
Sean had this really funny bit where he and his friend went on a trip once and they had to borrow a fan because Sean needs a fan in order to fall asleep. Oh, gosh. And cause he loves a fan. Yeah, so let's just grab anybody. Anybody who's seen Will and Grace or whatever,
肖恩有个非常有趣的段子，他和朋友有次去旅行，他们不得不借一个风扇，因为肖恩睡觉需要风扇。哦，天哪。因为他喜欢风扇。是啊，所以我们就随便抓个人。任何看过《威尔和格蕾丝》或者其他什么的人，
but he just needs a fan. Oh, a fan. No, no, no, sorry, I'm kidding. But a fan. Yeah, so let's just grab anybody. Anybody who's seen Will and Grace or whatever, but he just needs a fan. Oh, a fan, no. No, no, no, sorry, I'm kidding. But a fan, so he goes, he's at this hotel and they bring in a fan. They go, of course, because he's Sean Hayes of Will and Grace and they love him, their big fan. And they put the thing, they give him a fan,
但他就是需要一个风扇。哦，风扇。不，不，不，抱歉，我开玩笑的。但是风扇。是啊，所以我们就随便抓个人。任何看过《威尔和格蕾丝》或者其他什么的人，但他就是需要一个风扇。哦，风扇，不。不，不，不，抱歉，我开玩笑的。但是风扇，所以他说，他在酒店，他们拿来一个风扇。他们说，当然，因为他是《威尔和格蕾丝》里的肖恩·海耶斯，他们爱他，他们是他的大粉丝。他们把东西放好，给了他一个风扇，
it says, do not take out of the office, it says on the fan. So he and his friend, they were on this and they spent the whole night doing bits about the person who comes back to the office. And the fan's missing. And notices the fan is missing. Right, he's like, hold on. So then, like a month ago, we were at dinner,
上面写着，不要带出办公室，风扇上写着。所以他和他的朋友，他们在那儿，花了一整晚编段子，关于那个回到办公室的人。然后风扇不见了。并注意到风扇不见了。对，他就像，等等。所以，大概一个月前，我们在吃晚饭，
maybe two months ago, and we started doing, and everybody had to do their version of the boss coming back and- And you had to say, where's my fan? And where's my fan? And the line was, you couldn't change anything, you could do whatever you want, but you had to say, where's my fan? And where's my fan? And the line was, you couldn't change anything. You could do whatever you want, but you had to say, where's my fan?
也许两个月前，我们开始做这个，每个人都必须表演他们版本的那个老板回来——你必须说，我的风扇在哪？我的风扇在哪？台词是，你不能改变任何东西，你可以做任何你想做的事，但你必须说，我的风扇在哪？我的风扇在哪？台词是，你不能改变任何东西。你可以做任何你想做的事，但你必须说，我的风扇在哪？
Yeah, you can come in super happy and come up super mad. Fuck me, we did an hour on it. Where was this and where was I? It was fun. You had already gone home. It was after 7.30 PM. So you'd already gone to bed. I don't know where you were, JB,
是啊，你可以超级开心进来，也可以超级生气进来。去他的，我们在上面花了一个小时。这是在哪，我在哪？很有趣。你已经回家了。那是晚上7点半之后。所以你已经睡觉了。我不知道你在哪，JB，
because Amanda was there. So you come in. So Amy, you come in and you do this. You go, so you come in and you do this You go so you come in you go Hey guys, so we're gonna start the day Four through six has a real big issue with their sheets. We have to change their sheets Where's my fan? So fucking and then Sean and I started doing this bit we go, where we go? Yeah, man.
因为阿曼达在那儿。所以你进来。所以艾米，你进来，你做这个。你说，所以你进来，你做这个，你说，所以你进来，你说，嘿伙计们，我们要开始新的一天了，四到六号房的床单有个大问题。我们得换床单，我的风扇在哪？去他的，然后肖恩和我开始做这个段子，我们说，我们去哪？是啊，伙计。
Of course I know where that is. Hello, hello? And then you answer yourself, you surprise yourself. Oh, why is it so fun? We're dumb, we're very dumb. Speaking of dumb, what happens when you get some real dumb ass, lippy audience member that wants to just start talking to you or commenting on your joke,
我当然知道那在哪。喂，喂？然后你自己回答自己，你让自己感到惊讶。哦，为什么这么有趣？我们很蠢，我们非常蠢。说到蠢，当你遇到一些真正蠢透了、嘴欠的观众，他们只想开始跟你说话或者评论你的笑话时，会发生什么，
or at worst, heckling or something like that. You got any like, anything ever go really sideways? This is sort of a Sean Hayes question. You ever punch anybody from stage? Get down, walk down into the stands and... I have never physically assaulted anybody in the audience. We're not lawyers. Oh, all right.
或者最坏的情况，起哄或者类似的事情。你有过什么真正搞砸的情况吗？这算是个肖恩·海耶斯的问题。你有没有在台上打过人？走下台，走进观众席然后……我从来没有在观众面前身体攻击过任何人。我们不是律师。哦，好吧。
It was, look, one time, fucking. Yeah, no, I have like some YouTube videos showing me with hecklers over the years. Really? Oh, really? Yeah, yeah. I, you know, it's like every comic I think is because they had like a bad, you know,
那是，看，有一次，该死。是啊，不，我有一些YouTube视频展示了这些年来我应对起哄者的情况。真的吗？哦，真的吗？是啊，是啊。我，你知道，我觉得每个喜剧演员都是因为他们有过糟糕的，你知道，
labored childhood experience. Yeah, just trauma trauma. So, um, so, and, you know, I think people get into stand up because of the control of it. They like that it's a one sided conversation. So when it goes wrong, you're already you're pretty defensive. So I'm ready. You're ready. And,, and you know, the goal is to get like a big laugh. And, and, but some comics, you know, will take it too far. And you just see that they're,
痛苦的童年经历。是啊，就是创伤，创伤。所以，嗯，所以，而且，你知道，我认为人们进入单口喜剧是因为它的控制感。他们喜欢这种单向的对话。所以当事情出错时，你已经相当防御了。所以我准备好了。你准备好了。而且，而且你知道，目标是获得大笑。而且，而且，但有些喜剧演员，你知道，会做得太过火。你只是看到他们，
and it ruins the show. Cause you just see that they're, yeah, they're really sad and angry. They're too affected by it. That's the thing you've got to avoid. I'm, I'm, I'm guessing right. You can't, can't, don't make the audience tight or tense or. The best thing I have seen is just to diffuse it.
这毁了演出。因为你只是看到他们，是啊，他们真的很悲伤和愤怒。他们受到的影响太大了。那是你必须避免的事情。我，我，我猜对吧。你不能，不能，不要让观众感到紧张或紧绷，或者。我见过的最好的事情就是化解它。
Honestly, like I think that's the pro move. They go like, you suck. You go like, thanks dad or you know, like whatever. Just try to keep the show moving. Cause it's like, you know, it's a fun little, that's the best. I think that's the pro move. Sean, are you crying? I'm a little bit. like, you know, it's a fun little, that's the, I think that's the, that's the pro. Sean, are you crying? A little bit.
老实说，我觉得那是专业做法。他们说，你真烂。你说，谢谢爸爸，或者你知道，随便什么。试着让演出继续进行。因为这就像，你知道，这是一个有趣的小段子，那是最好的。我觉得那是专业做法。肖恩，你在哭吗？我有一点。就像，你知道，这是一个有趣的小段子，那是，我觉得那是，那是专业的。肖恩，你在哭吗？有一点。
Sean, why? When you're not doing it, Aimee, do you, I cut everybody's fingers short. I love it. I love it. When you're not doing it, do you miss it? Do you crave it? Do you crave going back on when you're not like on tour
肖恩，为什么？当你不在做的时候，艾米，你，我把所有人的手指都剪短了。我喜欢它。我喜欢它。当你不在做的时候，你会想念它吗？你会渴望它吗？当你不在巡演的时候，你渴望回到舞台上吗？
and not doing it? Yeah, I do. I really miss it. I mean, it's, it's hard because it's like, you know, within your family, like no one like is interested in your career. Right, or your jokes. No, and so it's like to go on stage,
而不做它？是啊，我确实。我真的很想念它。我的意思是，这很难，因为就像，你知道，在你的家庭里，没有人对你的职业感兴趣。对，或者你的笑话。没有，所以就像上台，
like if I went to the cellar right now, I would go up and I would get a long applause and people would be excited to see me and I just can't really get used to that because Then you know you start thinking that they're right and like why is it you know? Am I important in my in my household and you know as you all know you're not yeah Nothing the last person to give it up anything for me is inside my house of course, so it's like yeah Same yeah to give up anything for me is inside my house. Of course. So it's like, yeah. You know.
如果我现在去地下室，我会上去，我会得到长时间的掌声，人们会很兴奋见到我，我真的无法习惯这一点，因为然后你知道你开始认为他们是对的，为什么是这样，你知道？我在我的家庭里很重要吗？而且你知道，正如你们所知，你并不重要。是啊，没什么，家里最后一个人会为我放弃任何东西，当然，所以就像，是啊。同样，是啊，为我放弃任何东西是在我家。当然。所以就像，是啊。你知道。
Same. Yeah, so it's a. No, it's not the same. But what about, so you might be listening to that. I'm a real hit at home to be honest. Is that true? I don't see that for you. That's funny.
同样。是啊，所以是一个。不，不是一样的。但关于，所以你可能在听那个。老实说，我在家里是个大红人。那是真的吗？我没看出来。那很有趣。
He does pretty well. Why not? No, I don't know. Let's just keep the conversation moving. Okay, but I just, but I do say, you know what's funny is, I totally hear that in, because it's not real and it's outsized for, you know, from your real life, meaning that we all have a relationship with our family
他做得很好。为什么不呢？不，我不知道。让我们继续谈话吧。好吧，但我只是，但我确实说，你知道什么很有趣，我完全听到了，因为那不是真实的，而且对于，你知道，你的现实生活来说太夸张了，意思是说我们都和家人有关系，
and so on and then you go on stage or you interact with fans and that kind of adulation is not normal. But I will also say that people, you know, people say like, oh, you like people who like you. And I go, yeah. What's wrong with that? Of course I do.
等等，然后你上台或者你和粉丝互动，那种奉承是不正常的。但我也会说，人们，你知道，人们说，哦，你喜欢喜欢你的人。我说，是啊。那有什么错？我当然喜欢。
What the fuck are you talking about? Will on Sunday was making me pee my pant, my stomach hurts so bad from laughing. And I turned to Alessandra, his baby mama, and I turned to Alessandra and I go, God, it never, I'm crying, laughing. I go, it just doesn't stop. And she goes from 6 a.m. to bedtime.
你在说什么鬼话？威尔周日让我笑得尿裤子了，我的肚子因为笑得太厉害而疼。我转向亚历山德拉，他的孩子他妈，我转向亚历山德拉说，天哪，它从来，我笑得流泪了。我说，它就是停不下来。她说从早上6点到睡觉。
Yeah, this is while she was cleaning her gun or was she loading it? I love it. While you love the immediate gratification and feedback of a standup stage, you're doing way more sort of like on-camera stuff now than you ever were before, almost more so than stand-up work, right?
是啊，这是在她擦枪的时候，还是她在装子弹？我喜欢它。虽然你喜欢单口喜剧舞台的即时满足感和反馈，但你现在做的镜头前的东西比以前多多了，几乎比单口喜剧工作还多，对吧？
So how are you able to get the same amount of gratification with it just being in front of a crew and hoping that later the editor and the marketing and all that stuff comes like, how do you, what's the gratification of doing the on-camera stuff? Is it equal to it? Is it more? I love the process.
那么你是如何获得同样程度的满足感的，仅仅是在剧组面前，并希望以后剪辑师和营销人员等等能跟上，你是怎么，做镜头前的东西的满足感是什么？它相等吗？更多吗？我喜欢这个过程。
I like, you know, I know. This interview is over. No, I know, I know, I know. We don't find that word. That word's okay. Okay, I'm allowed to say process, okay. Don't say storyteller. I will not, I will not.
我喜欢，你知道，我知道。这次采访结束了。不，我知道，我知道，我知道。我们找不到那个词。那个词没问题。好吧，我被允许说过程，好吧。别说讲故事的人。我不会，我不会。
Okay, contact the snipersers if you have a shot. Take the shot. Just to be so honored to be part of telling, we're storytellers. Oh, that's fucking it. Take the shot. No, I love a writer's room. Like I love collaborating, I love like, you know.
好吧，如果你有镜头，联系狙击手。开枪。能成为讲述的一部分真是太荣幸了，我们是讲故事的人。哦，那真是该死的。开枪。不，我喜欢编剧室。就像我喜欢合作，我喜欢，你知道。
How do you like directing? You've been doing that too. Do you like that sort of collaborative process? I love it. I was, you know, I was doing it before I was credited to do it. So, you know, it's like, that's the truth. So yeah, and I love doing it with like my crew, you know?
你喜欢导演吗？你也一直在做那个。你喜欢那种协作过程吗？我喜欢。我，你知道，我在被认可做它之前就在做了。所以，你知道，就像，那是事实。所以是啊，我喜欢和我的剧组一起做，你知道？
Like with, like I always work with Dan Palkev and Kay and then Ryan McFall and we kind of all do it together. And but directing, I love it. Yeah, as opposed to that sort of that solo thing of being on stage, it's a completely different thing, right, but you love it just as much, huh? Yeah, it's isolating. And then what about the writing process
就像和，就像我总是和丹·帕尔凯夫和凯，还有瑞安·麦克福尔一起工作，我们基本上是一起做。但导演，我喜欢。是啊，相对于那种在舞台上的孤独感，这是完全不同的事情，对吧，但你同样喜欢它，嗯？是啊，这很孤立。那关于写作过程呢？
of scripts versus stand-up stuff? So you're in your bed, like writing train reference, which by the way is one of my favorite books of all time. Love, crazy. Thank you. Love, nice. It's so really good. Jud just crushed that. Did you, was that a fantastic experience or was it a lot more work than you had anticipated
剧本对比单口喜剧？所以你在床上，像写火车参考，顺便说一句，这是我最喜欢的书之一。爱，疯狂。谢谢。爱，不错。真的很好。贾德刚刚搞定了。你，那是一次美妙的经历，还是比你预期的工作量大得多？
and if so, was it worth it? It was totally fun. Yeah. And it was completely worth it and amazing. And I was like afraid of becoming famous, but it's been okay. What do you guys think about it? Do you?
如果是这样，值得吗？这完全很有趣。是啊。而且完全值得，太棒了。我当时害怕变得出名，但还好。你们觉得怎么样？你们？
I loved it. And I also think- No, I mean being famous. I think you're a great famous person by the way. Really? Yeah, I like the way you, no, I do like the way you treat fame. You're very un-precious about it.
我喜欢它。而且我也认为——不，我是说出名。顺便说一句，我觉得你是个很棒的名人。真的吗？是啊，我喜欢你的方式，不，我确实喜欢你对待名声的方式。你对此一点也不矫情。
You're very humble about it. You're hilarious about it. You don't take it too seriously, yet you're very serious about what it is you're doing. You seem to have an incredible role. Well, you're very honest. Thank you. You're very sort of open and transparent
你对此非常谦虚。你对此非常搞笑。你不会太认真对待它，但你对你正在做的事情非常认真。你似乎有一个不可思议的角色。好吧，你很诚实。谢谢。你非常开放和透明，
and very honest about how you feel about stuff. And so you're not held captive by it. Sometimes people can be so nervous about losing it or presenting the right way or whatever. You seem to be very honest. I don't, again, don't know you that well. I didn't even know you had your uterus removed. But I do, I do get this. That's not my uterus. That's a prop uterus, by the way. That's not a conical uterus. That means a lot. I can't believe I just back myself into these compliments. No, but it's true.
而且对你的感受非常诚实。所以你不会被它俘虏。有时人们会因为失去它或者以正确的方式呈现它而感到非常紧张。你似乎非常诚实。我，再说一次，不太了解你。我甚至不知道你切除了子宫。但我确实，我确实明白了。那不是我的子宫。顺便说一句，那是道具子宫。那不是圆锥形子宫。那意义重大。我不敢相信我刚才把自己逼进了这些赞美中。不，但这是真的。
Sean, did you want to add anything? I actually had a question about that. It's not really time for questions. Sean's been very vocal about that. He does not like fame on you. Yeah. Well, you said Sean is famously quoted women aren't funny, you know, famously. Yeah, it is.
肖恩，你想补充什么吗？我其实有个关于那个的问题。现在不是提问的时候。肖恩对此一直非常直言不讳。他不喜欢你出名。是啊。好吧，你说肖恩被著名地引用说女人不好笑，你知道，著名地。是啊，确实。
By the way, he pre made his gravestone to say that. That's all, and he had it made years ago. It's waiting for him to die. You already sleep under it, which I think was his dream choice. I just try to get acclimated. To each, you know, that's what they say. Do you think, Amy, will women ever be funny?
顺便说一句，他预先制作了他的墓碑来写那个。就是这样，而且他几年前就做好了。它在等着他死。你已经睡在它下面了，我觉得那是他梦想的选择。我只是试着去适应。每个人，你知道，他们就是这么说的。你认为，艾米，女人会变得好笑吗？
No, no, it's just that. It's Sean's question. It's Sean's question. Okay, Sean, thank you for that question. I just checked and wrote that question. No, Amy, my question was about that though. Sean's question. It's Sean's question. Okay, Sean, thank you for that question. I just texted Will that question. No, Amy, my question was about that though. I was just starting to write down a question about how open you are,
不，不，只是那个。这是肖恩的问题。这是肖恩的问题。好吧，肖恩，谢谢你的提问。我刚才检查并写下了那个问题。不，艾米，我的问题是关于那个的。肖恩的问题。这是肖恩的问题。好吧，肖恩，谢谢你的提问。我刚才给威尔发短信问了那个问题。不，艾米，我的问题是关于那个的。我刚开始写一个关于你有多开放的问题，
how about being body positive, you seem to always be on the right side of every issue. At least I follow you on Instagram. And I'm like, yes, yes, like every time you post something. And thank you for your support. Yes, about every time you post something. And thank you for your support. Yes, about every time you post something about an opinion, or I agree with it, and I love your voice basically. Thank you.
关于身体积极性，你似乎总是站在每个问题的正确一边。至少我在Instagram上关注你。我当时想，是的，是的，就像你每次发帖一样。谢谢你的支持。是的，关于你每次发帖。谢谢你的支持。是的，关于你每次发帖发表意见，或者我同意它，我基本上喜欢你的声音。谢谢。
So when did you ever, were you ever not like that? And was there a defining moment when you're like, you know what, I gotta get out of my shell and start, you know, life is bigger than just me and my career, my family. I have to actually start expressing myself about bigger issues that include everybody. Was there something that pushed you that way?
所以你什么时候，你曾经不是那样吗？有没有一个决定性的时刻，你觉得，你知道吗，我得走出我的壳，开始，你知道，生活比我个人和我的职业、我的家庭更大。我必须真正开始表达自己关于包括每个人的更大问题。有什么东西推动你那样做吗？
Or was there like, wait a minute, I gotta get off the couch and do something? No, I'm on the couch as you know, like that's for me. I'm in the bed, but no, I was always like this. I was always open in my app and couldn't really, yeah, I didn't know what it meant to be a feminist like Will. It just means like thinking of women equally. Finally.
或者有没有像，等一下，我得从沙发上起来做点什么？不，我在沙发上，如你所知，就像那对我来说。我在床上，但不，我一直都是这样。我一直很开放，不能真正，是啊，我不知道像威尔那样成为女权主义者意味着什么。它只是意味着像平等地看待女性。终于。
But at some point you didn't care what people, was there a shift? No, everyone always, I care what people think. It's like, what kind of an actual sociopath doesn't care. Right, well, that's kind of my point. It's not that you don't care what people think. It's that you're willing to risk saying what you believe in and be honest
但在某个时候你不在乎人们，有没有转变？不，每个人总是，我在乎人们怎么想。就像，什么样的真正反社会者不在乎。对，好吧，那正是我的观点。不是说你不在乎人们怎么想。而是你愿意冒险说出你相信的东西并保持诚实，
and no matter what people think. And of course, as human beings, we all take that shit on and I don't care who you are. You can read a comment, you can read a review, you can read a thing and it'll hurt your feelings because we are human beings. But the ability to continue to be honest and true to your what you believe,
无论人们怎么想。当然，作为人类，我们都承受着那些狗屁，我不在乎你是谁。你可以读评论，你可以读评论，你可以读东西，它会伤害你的感情，因为我们是人类。但继续保持诚实并忠于你所相信的东西的能力，
I think is very admirable. Considering that it's much more, you're in a high profile position. So there you go. I will thank you. Sean doesn't say fuck all, I wish he would. But he doesn't take a position on fucking anything. You know what Sean's big, you know what Sean's big causes?
我认为是非常令人钦佩的。考虑到它更多，你处于一个高调的位置。所以给你。我会谢谢你。肖恩什么都不说，我希望他会。但他对任何该死的事情都不采取立场。你知道肖恩的大，你知道肖恩的大事业是什么吗？
You know what he made a big position last year? He said that a G550 was way better than a G5. Yeah, that was you, right, that was you. No, I think that was a good sort to fall in, Sean. That was brave, that was brave. We'll be right back. So, Martin, let's get support from Audible. Audible lets you enjoy all your audio entertainment We'll be right back. motivation, wellness, business, and so much more. Audible is your destination for thrilling audio entertainment with highly anticipated new releases
你知道他去年采取了什么大立场吗？他说G550比G5好得多。是啊，那是你，对吧，那是你。不，我觉得那是个很好的落脚点，肖恩。那很勇敢，那很勇敢。我们马上回来。所以，马丁，让我们从Audible获得支持。Audible让你享受所有的音频娱乐，我们马上回来。动力、健康、商业等等。Audible是您享受激动人心的音频娱乐的目的地，有备受期待的新版本，
and next listen recommendations for every type of thriller listener. As an Audible member, you could choose one title a month to keep from the entire catalog, including the latest bestsellers and new releases. So I love, as you well know, sci-fi. And I saw the sequel to Dune.
以及为每种类型的惊悚片听众推荐的下一次收听。作为Audible会员，您可以从整个目录中选择一个标题每月保留，包括最新的畅销书和新版本。所以我喜欢，如你所知，科幻。我看了《沙丘》的续集。
I loved the first one. I loved the sequel. It was so, so good, but I never read the book. So what I did was I went back on Audible and I started listening to Dune by Frank Herbert. It's narrated by a ton of super talented people doing lots of different voices. And it's like, it's a thrill to listen to.
我喜欢第一部。我喜欢续集。它太，太好了，但我从来没读过书。所以我做的是我回到Audible，我开始听弗兰克·赫伯特的《沙丘》。它由一大堆超级有才华的人叙述，做了很多不同的声音。这就像，听起来很刺激。
And if you don't know Dune, or you might be interested in listening to it on Audible, it's like, it's's a awesome sci-fi adventure that has mysticism and binomialism and politics and all these great themes. I loved it. Absolutely loved it. New members can try Audible free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartlist or text smartlist to 500-500. That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500 500 to try audible free for 30 days audible.com slash smartless This show is sponsored by better help So what's the first thing you do if you had an extra hour in your day for me?
如果你不知道《沙丘》，或者你可能有兴趣在Audible上听它，它就像，它是一个很棒的科幻冒险，有神秘主义和二项式主义和政治以及所有这些伟大的主题。我喜欢它。绝对喜欢它。新会员可以免费试用Audible 30天。访问audible.com斜杠smartlist或发送短信smartlist到500-500。那是audible.com斜杠smartless或发送短信smartless到500 500免费试用Audible 30天audible.com斜杠smartless这个节目由BetterHelp赞助，所以如果你的一天多出一个小时，你做的第一件事是什么？
I feel like if there's an hour that I'm not creating something or doing something or you know pushing myself forward is an hour wasted But through therapy I had to learn how to balance my life from too much ambition and filling every single hour and taking time for myself, which was kind of a new concept for me. And it's a good thing I'm still working on it, but I only learned it through therapy. The question is, for you guys,
我觉得如果有一个小时我没有创造什么或者做点什么或者你知道推动自己前进，那就是浪费了一个小时。但通过治疗，我不得不学习如何平衡我的生活，从太多的野心和填满每一个小时，到为自己留出时间，这对我来说是一个新概念。这是一件好事，我还在努力，但我只是通过治疗才学到的。问题是，对于你们来说，
what would you have time for if you had an extra hour? If time was unlimited, how would you use it? How would you decide what's important enough to make time for? Therapy can help you find what matters to you so you can do more of it. If you're thinking of starting therapy give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists any time for no additional charge. Learn to make time for what makes you happy with BetterHelp. matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge.
如果你有一个额外的小时，你会有时间做什么？如果时间是无限的，你会怎么用它？你会如何决定什么重要到值得腾出时间？治疗可以帮助你找到对你重要的事情，这样你就可以做更多。如果你正在考虑开始治疗，给BetterHelp一个机会。它完全在线，旨在方便、灵活，并适合你的日程安排。只需填写一份简短的问卷，即可与持证治疗师匹配，并随时更换治疗师，无需额外费用。学习为让你快乐的事情腾出时间，与BetterHelp一起。与持证治疗师匹配，并随时更换治疗师，无需额外费用。
Learn to make time for what makes you happy with BetterHelp. Visit BetterHelp.com slash SmartList today to get 10% off your first month that's BetterHelpHELP.com slash SmartList. SmartList gets support from CarShield. Many of us spend a good chunk of our time in the car. Whether you're driving to work or planning a fun road trip with friends, you wanna make sure your car is in top shape
学习为让你快乐的事情腾出时间，与BetterHelp一起。今天访问BetterHelp.com斜杠SmartList可获得首月10%的折扣，那是BetterHelpHELP.com斜杠SmartList。SmartList获得CarShield的支持。我们很多人在车里花了很多时间。无论你是开车去上班还是计划和朋友进行有趣的公路旅行，你都想确保你的车处于最佳状态，
to handle any drive. But if you have been in the same car for years, you might worry about future breakdowns, right? I know I do. Don't let the stress of paperwork or headaches of repairs keep you from getting where you need to be. With CarShield, all you need to do is give them a call, choose the mechanic, and they handle the rest.
以应对任何驾驶。但如果你多年来一直开同一辆车，你可能会担心未来的故障，对吧？我知道我担心。不要让文书工作的压力或维修的头痛阻止你到达你需要去的地方。有了CarShield，你所要做的就是给他们打个电话，选择机械师，他们处理剩下的事情。
Car Shield plans provide protection on up to 5,000 major parts and systems, including big ticket items like your transmission, engine, and even your entertainment system. Plus, plans include exclusive access to Car Shield's Concierge service, as well as 24-7 roadside assistance, and help with flat or damaged tires, lockouts,
Car Shield计划提供对多达5,000个主要部件和系统的保护，包括像你的变速箱、发动机甚至你的娱乐系统这样的大件物品。此外，计划包括独家访问Car Shield的礼宾服务，以及24-7路边援助，并帮助处理爆胎或损坏的轮胎、锁车，
or rental car options. With CarShield, road chips have never been easier. Avoid the hassle of costly car repairs with CarShield. Visit carshield.com slash smartless and save 20% today. Again, that's carshield.com slash smartless to save 20%. Visit carshield.com slash smartless to lock in your price today. Visit carshield.com slash smartless to lock in your price today. SmartList gets support from Zip Recruiter. Tis the month of St. Patty's Day. And here's a random related fact. Did you know that the odds of finding a lucky four-leaf clover are 1 in 10,000? I'd say that's pretty difficult.
或租车选项。有了CarShield，公路旅行从未如此简单。避免昂贵的汽车维修麻烦，使用CarShield。访问carshield.com斜杠smartless并节省20%。再说一次，那是carshield.com斜杠smartless以节省20%。访问carshield.com斜杠smartless以锁定你今天的价格。访问carshield.com斜杠smartless以锁定你今天的价格。SmartList获得Zip Recruiter的支持。这是圣帕特里克节的月份。这里有一个随机的相关事实。你知道找到幸运四叶草的几率是1万分之一吗？我会说这相当困难。
Fortunately, if you're a business owner or hiring manager, you don't need luck to find top talent for your team. You need Zip Recruiter. And right now, you can try it for free at ziprecruiter.com slash smartlist. Zip Recruiter's powerful matching technology shows you qualified matches right after you post your job. Once you review your list of qualified candidates,
幸运的是，如果你是企业主或招聘经理，你不需要运气来为你的团队找到顶尖人才。你需要Zip Recruiter。现在，你可以在ziprecruiter.com斜杠smartlist免费试用。Zip Recruiter强大的匹配技术会在你发布工作后立即向你展示合格的匹配。一旦你审查了你的合格候选人名单，
you can easily invite them to apply. Aren't you just a wee bit curious to see how Zip Recruiter can help you? Well, today's your lucky day because you can try ZipRecruiter for free. Just go to ZipRecruiter.com slash smartless. In fact, four out of five employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate
你可以轻松邀请他们申请。你难道不好奇Zip Recruiter能如何帮助你吗？好吧，今天是你的幸运日，因为你可以免费试用ZipRecruiter。只需前往ZipRecruiter.com斜杠smartless。事实上，在ZipRecruiter上发布职位的雇主中，有五分之四的人获得了高质量的候选人，
within the first day. Once again, just go to this exclusive web address to try ZipRecruiter for free. That's ZipRecruiter.com slash smartless. ZipRecruiter, the smartest way to hire. That's zipper cruder.com slash smart less zipper cruder the smartest way to hire And back to the show Was your it was your is your cousin Chuck Schumer helpful in my son your son Chuck Schumer
在第一天内。再一次，只需前往这个独家网址免费试用ZipRecruiter。那是ZipRecruiter.com斜杠smartless。ZipRecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。那是zipper cruder.com斜杠smart less zipper cruder最聪明的招聘方式，回到节目。你的，你的，你的表弟查克·舒默对我的儿子，你的儿子查克·舒默有帮助吗？
The great senator Chuck Schumer was- Fuck, I got a Wikipedia U. My baby boy. I've got to Google you right now. Is he helpful at all in sort of navigating that place of like, you know, you can care what people think, but it's okay to bake in the fact that some people are not going to like what you think, and that shouldn't prevent you from, you know, in his case, enacting legislation
伟大的参议员查克·舒默是——该死，我有一个维基百科U。我的宝贝儿子。我现在必须谷歌你。他在导航那个地方方面有帮助吗，就像，你知道，你可以关心人们怎么想，但把一些人不会喜欢你的想法的事实考虑进去是可以的，那不应该阻止你，你知道，在他的情况下，制定立法，
that serves, you know, a lot more than some and- We've never talked about it actually. No. He very much is with me like, how like, you know, calls on like Jean's birthday and whatever we have like talked about, you know, things over the years, but there, we've never talked about the hate that comes with it.
服务于，你知道，比一些人多得多，而且——我们其实从来没谈过这个。不。他非常和我一样，就像，你知道，在吉恩的生日打电话，无论我们有什么，你知道，多年来谈论过事情，但那里，我们从来没谈过随之而来的仇恨。
I think, I think the way he feels, I'm just projecting, is how I feel where it feels like more of an opportunity to help than the responsibility to use my voice. Yeah, utilizing the platform. It is like, I would be so tempted. It's like, Will, you're buddies with with Shanahan runs the Toronto Maple Leafs. I don't know how you're able to avoid calling him every day with an idea for a new player. Like I would be calling Senator Chuck Schumer every day
我想，我想他感觉的方式，我只是在投射，是我感觉的方式，它感觉更像是一个帮助的机会，而不是使用我的声音的责任。是啊，利用平台。这就像，我会很想。这就像，威尔，你和肖纳汉是好朋友，他经营多伦多枫叶队。我不知道你是怎么避免每天打电话给他，提出一个新球员的想法的。就像我会每天打电话给参议员查克·舒默，
with an idea for how we can make this world better. They'd be dumb ideas, because I'm not bright, but I would just like, I got a bat line to somebody who's- I tell him about the Maple Leafs actually, I call him. You do? That's the- I tell him about the Maple Leafs actually, I call him. You do? That's the advice I give him. You fucking, you just, oh my God,
提出一个关于我们如何让这个世界变得更好的想法。那会是愚蠢的想法，因为我不聪明，但我只是想，我有一个直接联系某人的热线，他是——我其实告诉他关于枫叶队的事，我打电话给他。你做到了？那是——我告诉他关于枫叶队的事，我打电话给他。你做到了？那是给他的建议。你该死的，你只是，哦，天哪，
I can't even stand up. I can't stand up right now. Did you just ejaculate without a wrap? You, is it apparent? Wait, is it true that his name is Chuck? It was never Charles. He was born, it's just Chuck, sure. No, his name is Charles.
我甚至站不起来。我现在站不起来。你刚才没有包装就射精了吗？你，这很明显吗？等等，他的名字叫查克是真的吗？从来不是查尔斯。他出生时，只是查克，当然。不，他的名字是查尔斯。
Okay. Well, I'm gonna cross that out. Yeah, his name is Charles. What websites are you gonna cross that out. Yeah, his name is Charles. What websites are you on? Yeah, wait a minute. Did you just- Well, during the pandemic, I fucks, I'm sorry guys.
好吧。好吧，我会划掉那个。是啊，他的名字是查尔斯。你在什么网站上划掉那个。是啊，他的名字是查尔斯。你在什么网站上？是啊，等等。你刚才——好吧，在疫情期间，我该死，对不起伙计们。
Oh wow. He used to play stick ball with my dad. Like he's just like a sweet, like Brooklyn dude. Is that true? Yeah. So what is that? Is your whole family very sort of involved? I mean, obviously he's, but is your whole family very sort of involved? I mean, obviously he's,
哦，哇。他过去常和我爸爸玩棍球。就像他只是一个甜美的，就像布鲁克林哥们。那是真的吗？是啊。所以那是什么？你的整个家庭非常，你知道，参与其中吗？我的意思是，显然他是，但你的整个家庭非常，你知道，参与其中吗？我的意思是，显然他是，
but is your whole family very much involved in, I don't know, or have they always been involved in politics or was he an outlier? Yeah, he's the only one. My family, but it's cool. I did that show of finding your roots. Did you guys ever do that? Haven't, yeah.
但你的整个家庭非常参与，我不知道，或者他们一直参与政治，还是他是一个局外人？是啊，他是唯一一个。我的家庭，但这很酷。我做了那个寻找你的根源的节目。你们做过吗？没有，是啊。
I did, who do you think you are? Which is part of the same thing. I found out my family, like that. I've never seen a person like that. I've never seen a person like that. I've never seen a person like that. I've never seen a person like that. I've never seen a person like that. I've never seen a person like that. I've never seen a person like that. I've never seen a person like that. I've never seen a person like that. I've never seen a person like that.
我做了，你以为你是谁？这是同一件事的一部分。我发现我的家庭，像那样。我从来没见过那样的人。我从来没见过那样的人。我从来没见过那样的人。我从来没见过那样的人。我从来没见过那样的人。我从来没见过那样的人。我从来没见过那样的人。我从来没见过那样的人。我从来没见过那样的人。我从来没见过那样的人。
I've never seen a person like that. I've never seen a person like that. I've never seen a person like that. I've never seen a person like that. I've never seen a person like that. I've never seen a person like that. I've never seen a person like that. I've never seen a person like that.
我从来没见过那样的人。我从来没见过那样的人。我从来没见过那样的人。我从来没见过那样的人。我从来没见过那样的人。我从来没见过那样的人。我从来没见过那样的人。我从来没见过那样的人。
我从来没见过那样的人。我从来没见过那样的人。我从来没见过那样的人。我从来没见过那样的人。我从来没见过那样的人。我从来没见过那样的人。我从来没见过那样的人。我从来没见过那样的人。以那种方式政治化，但没有其他人担任公职。你的研究追溯到多久以前？是啊，它追溯到哪里？它追溯到1500年代。真的吗？哇，哇。
I've never seen a person like that. I've never seen a person like that. I've never seen a person like that. I've never seen a person like that. I've never seen a person like that. I've never seen a person like that. I've never seen a person like that. I've never seen a person like that. in that way political, but nobody else is sort of in office. How far back did your research go? Yeah, where did it go to? It went 1500s. Really? Wow, wow.
我想那不是，是那样吗？我的意思是，对于欧洲，他们就像，哦，太棒了。但对于我们来说，它就像，哇。有什么超级有趣的事情或者你不想听的事情吗？他们在哪里？他们追溯到哪里？我们在现在被认为是乌克兰的地方。Viznits是犹太人居住的小镇。
I guess that's not, is that that? I mean, for Europe, they're like, oh, great. But for us, it's like, wow. Anything super interesting or stuff you didn't want to hear? Where were they? Where did they go back to? We were in what would now be considered Ukraine. Viznits is the town for the Jewish side.
然后另一边是伦敦。很早就来到马萨诸塞州定居。我家庭的那一边，那时，他们中的几个被偷走并被带入奴隶制。这听起来太成问题了，但这确实是发生了什么。他们被偷走并被带入奴隶制，在加拿大被这些不同的部落。而且是啊，而且——他们来自Arnett部落吗？是啊，是啊，不，这确实是真的。
And then the other side was London. Came over settled pretty early in Massachusetts. That side of my family, back then, a couple of them were stolen and brought into slavery with these. This sounds like so problematic, but this is really what happened. They were stolen and brought into slavery up in Canada for a couple of these different tribes. And yeah, and- Are they from the Arnett tribe? Yeah, yeah, no, this is really true.
然后，而且我的，所以就像30年后，他们就像，我的家庭赚了足够的钱去尝试营救他们。哇。当他们到达那里时，这是如此，我是认真的，他们是，他们是，当他们到达那里去营救他的两个兄弟和被偷走并卖为奴隶的妹妹时，
And then, and my, so like 30 years later, they like, my family made enough to like go and try and rescue them. Wow. And when they got up there, this is so, I'm serious, they were, they were, when they got up there to rescue his two brothers and his sister who'd been stolen and sold into slavery,
他们在管理部落。他们不想离开，因为现在他们负责部落。他们变成了库尔茨上校。是啊。所以这有点狂野。这，这真是该死的疯狂。不可能。
they were running the tribe. They didn't want to leave because now they were in charge of the tribe. They became Colonel Kurtz. Yeah. So that's kind of wild. That's, that is fucking crazy. No way.
所以他们留在加拿大管理部落还是什么？是啊。在那之后我联系了，我现在和一些远房表亲有联系。哦，那很狂野。因为那个节目。是啊。然后我确实有一个——
So did they stay in Canada running the tribe or whatever? Yeah. And I reached after that show and I reached out and I'm in touch with some distant cousins now. Oh, that's wild. Because of that show. Yeah. And then I do have a-
你就像，该死，再也别打这里了，嗯？该死的。去他的。我们很好。我的意思是，说真的，那不是丹尼·麦克布莱德在某部电影里的事吗？就像，那确实发生在我家庭的事，你知道，我确实来自一个长长的，
You're like, fucking never call here again, eh? Fucking hell. Fuck it. We're good. I mean, seriously, like, wasn't that Danny McBride's thing in some movie? Like, that's really what happened with my family, which, you know, I do come from a long line
人们是，你知道，战士，而且，你知道，只是，你知道，我的，我有像，四个大屠杀幸存者在我的家庭里，所以不可思议，我做了我的，丽莎·库卓制作了一个节目叫你以为你是谁，所以我做了它，而且它，你知道，我不得不去爱尔兰了解我们的祖先，在大多数情况下，他们都是醉酒、混乱和在监狱里。真的吗？是啊，这很不错。你说你的整个家庭。他们，他们都是醉酒和混乱，在监狱里。真的吗？是啊。这很狂野。
of people who are, you know, fighters and, you know, just, you know, my, I have like, for Holocaust survivors in my family so Unbelievable I did my I did Lisa Kudrow Produces a show called who do you think you are and so I did it and I it was you know I had to go to Ireland and learn about our ancestors and for the most part they were all drunk disorderly and in jail Really? Yeah, it's pretty well. You're saying your whole family. They were, they were all drunk and disorderly and in jail. Really? Yeah. It was pretty wild.
等等，所以你是说你的整个家庭，他们都在监狱里，他们都是什么？就像醉酒和混乱，一次又一次被捕。他们在爱尔兰喝酒？是啊。那很有趣。我不敢相信。你有读过任何指控吗？就像，报纸上有具体的指控吗？
Wait, so you're saying your whole family, they were all in jail and they were all what? Like drunk and disorderly and got arrested over and over again. They were drinking in Ireland? Yeah. That's fun. I can't believe that. Did you get to read any of the charges? Like was it, were there specific charges in the paper?
是啊。报纸上有一篇在像八，像1800年代中期或1800年代末。报纸上有一篇小文章，他有一些，我的曾曾祖父，祖父，曾曾曾祖父，我记得，对法庭有一些像讽刺的俏皮话。就像我不记得那是什么了，但它很有趣。哦，你知道我想说什么吗？
Yeah. There was one in the paper in like the eight, like middle 1800s or late 1800s. And there's a little article in the paper that he had some, my great-great grandfather, grandfather, great-great-great grandfather, I remember, had some like sarcastic quip to the courtroom. Like I don't remember what it was, but it was funny. Oh, and you know what I wanted to say?
而且只是为了跟进那个，我的曾祖母几年前去世了。她是个私酒贩子，她的酒铺还在54街。舒默的酒铺。不可能。是啊。不可能。是啊，是啊。
And just to piggyback off that, my great- died a couple years ago. She was a bootlegger and her liquor store is still on 54th Street. Schumer's Lickers. No way. Yeah. No freaking way. Yeah, yeah.
那很狂野。是啊，所以，但她，我的意思是，这很疯狂。她卖，田纳西·威廉姆斯是常客。我讨厌这样做，但我喜欢这样做。你有任何来自媒体秀的有趣剧院故事吗？哦，天哪。就像任何出错的事情，或者只是像，哦，天哪，有一天这件可怕的事情。
That's wild. Yeah, so, but she, I mean, it's crazy. She sold, Tennessee Williams was a regular customer. I hate to do this, but I love to do this too. Do you have any funny theater stories from Media Shower? Oh my God. Like anything that went wrong, or just like, oh my God, one night this horrible thing.
好吧，这让你了解我的一点行为。是啊。你知道，他们为林肯中心的表演艺术图书馆拍摄了百老汇演出的一晚。是的，所以他们拍摄我们的那一晚，我在演出中间有一个像速度，像独白。前排的某个人拿出了，
Okay, this lets you know about my behavior a little bit. Yeah. You know, they film one of the nights of the Broadway show for the Forming Arts Library up in Lincoln Center. Yes, and so the night they were filming us, I had like a speed, like a monologue in the middle of the show. And someone in the front row took out
正如他们在大多数百老汇演出中卖的那样，花生M&Ms。他们坐在离我五英尺远的地方，他们打开M&Ms，开始吃它们，我正试图通过我的嘴。你知道，你就像在说台词，但你，然后最后我只是像看着他们，我当时就像花生M&Ms，就在现在。
as they sell in the most Broadway shows, Peanut M&Ms. And they're sitting five feet away from me and they open up the M&Ms and they start eating them and I'm trying to get through my mouth. You know, you're like saying the words, but you're, and then finally I just like looked at them and I was like peanut M&Ms like right now.
哇。他们只是停止咀嚼了吗？他们，这是一个年轻人，他给了我一个眼神，就像，就像你是对的。你知道，就像这不是一个好时机。我们只是，你知道，继续。那不是一个非常严肃的剧。是啊，那真的很有趣。
Wow. Did they just freeze chewing? They, it was this young guy and he gave me a look like, like you're right. You know, like this wasn't a good timing. We just, you know, carried on. It wasn't a very serious play. Yeah, that's really funny.
我有同样的事情。我的意思是，我正在做一个叫上帝的行为的独角戏，我在里面扮演上帝，长话短说。但无论如何，在前排，向上帝发誓，同样的事情。花生M&Ms。花生M&Ms，是的。我看着他们，因为在我的脑海里，我当时想，我不能继续了。我必须，看着这个家伙。
I had the same thing. I mean, I was doing a one man show called an act of God where I was playing God long story. But anyway, in the front row swear to God, same thing. Peanut M&M's. Peanut M&M's, yep. And I looked at them because in my head, I was like, I can't keep going. I have to, and watch this guy.
所以我只是说，你知道，我停下来看着他。我说，你知道，这不是电影。这是一个现场。不，他们真的不知道。他们真的不知道。这是一个现场演出，有第四面墙是不存在的。好吧，看《法国共和国的祈祷》，这就像这个惊人的剧。很多百老汇演出的观众都是90岁及以上。
So I just said, you know, I stopped and I looked at him. I said, you know, this isn't a movie. This is a live. No, they really don't. They really don't know that. This is a live show and there's the fourth wall that is not there. Well, seeing Prayer for the French Republic, it's like this amazing play. And a lot of the audience for Broadway shows are 90 and above.
所以我当时就说，你知道，我停下来看着他。我说，你知道，这不是电影。这是现场直播。不，他们真的不知道。他们真的不知道这一点。这是现场演出，而且这里没有所谓的第四面墙。嗯，去看《为法兰西共和国祈祷》，这真是一部了不起的剧。而且百老汇演出的很多观众都在90岁以上。
And you can hear the play, but you can also hear it through the hearing aids. They go, it's not working, so Broadway. What about hosting the Oscars? Anything that we didn't see that went no good? I think you saw it. I think you saw the sort of headline on that night. Well, I apologize.
你可以听到那部戏，但你也可以通过助听器听到。他们说，这没用，太百老汇了。那主持奥斯卡呢？有什么我们没看到但效果不好的吗？我想你看到了。我想你那天晚上看到了相关的头条新闻。好吧，我道歉。
I'm not remembering anything specific. Are you referencing something else? Oh, okay. There was like a little bit of a disagreement between, have you heard of Will Smith? Oh, yes, yes. Okay, he's an actor and yeah. And so he got into like a little thing
我不记得有什么具体的了。你是指别的事情吗？哦，好吧。当时有点分歧，你听说过威尔·史密斯吗？哦，是的，是的。好吧，他是个演员，是的。所以他卷入了一点小事
with another comedian, I can't remember something. Yeah, I remember us all being really knocked out by that, no pun intended. Mm, yeah, yeah. Can I just say, this is kind of out there, but I'm just gonna by that, no pun intended. Yeah, yeah. That was some. Can I just say, this is kind of out there, but I'm just gonna say it, I was surprised. Yeah, I think everyone except one was. I can't believe you went out on that lift.
和另一位喜剧演员，我不记得是什么了。是的，我记得我们都被那件事惊呆了，不是双关语。嗯，是的，是的。我能说吗，这有点离谱，但我还是要说，我很惊讶。是的，我想除了一个人以外，大家都很惊讶。我不敢相信你坐那个升降机出去了。
No, I don't wanna be like, you know, this will be the pull quote, but I was taken aback. Fuck. Dude, you and your controversial positions, that never stops. I'll say it. Was it a fun experience? Aside from that, it was the whole thing
不，我不想表现得，你知道，这会成为引语，但我确实感到吃惊。该死。伙计，你和你的争议性立场，这永远不会停止。我会说的。那是一次有趣的经历吗？除此之外，整件事
just kind of drowned out by it. No, it was totally fun. It was totally fun. It was like, I just wanted to do it, you know? And doing it with Regina and Wanda was so fun. Like I'd love preparing jokes when somebody else is gonna host something. I love helping them with jokes and putting on a show.
都被它掩盖了。不，这完全很有趣。这完全很有趣。就像，我只是想做这件事，你知道吗？和雷吉娜还有旺达一起做真的很有趣。就像当别人要主持什么节目时，我喜欢准备笑话。我喜欢帮他们写笑话，然后举办一场演出。
It felt like we were putting on a show and it was so fun. And I got to fly. I was like, I wanna go up on flies and I did like a sort of very stupid thing. But I feel like we did a really good job, honestly. Like I think if that hadn't happened, thanks. I think a takeaway would have been that we did a good job.
感觉我们是在举办一场演出，这太有趣了。而且我还能飞。我当时想，我想飞上去，我做了一件非常愚蠢的事情。但我真的觉得我们做得很好，老实说。就像我认为如果那件事没发生，谢谢。我想一个收获就是我们做得很好。
Yeah, I hope they do that again. Have they done three before? No, but. I don't think so, right? Yeah, but when it's women, they paid us all together the same as one man. No. No, I'm just kidding.
是的，我希望他们再做一次。他们以前做过三次吗？不，但是。我不这么认为，对吧？是的，但如果是女性，他们付给我们的钱和付给一个男人的钱一样多。不。不，我开玩笑的。
No, but what do you get for hosting that? Like, who knows? You're gonna have to tell us. Yeah. You should do it again. Would you, you would never do that? That's pretty. I don't know.
不，但主持那个节目能得到什么？谁知道呢？你得告诉我们。是的。你应该再做一次。你会吗，你永远不会那样做？那太……我不知道。
I don't, I mean, like earlier we were saying, I just don't know if I would be able to survive that. I just not great in front of a live audience being myself. Really? Don't you guys do this show in front of live audiences alone? No, this is just us. No, we have. No, you have.
我不知道，我的意思是，就像我们之前说的，我不知道我是否能挺过去。我在现场观众面前做我自己时表现不太好。真的吗？你们不是经常在现场观众面前做这个节目吗？不，这只是我们。不，我们有。不，你有。
We have. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, well, it wasn't comfortable. I mean, I had a good time, but that's very nerve-wracking for me. Well, and when you asked me to do the show, the timing just didn't work out with the road, but I was so honored.
我们有。是的，是的，是的。是的，好吧，那并不舒服。我的意思是，我玩得很开心，但这对我来说非常伤脑筋。嗯，当你邀请我做这个节目时，时间安排和巡演冲突了，但我感到非常荣幸。
You guys are all the funniest people ever. Everyone I know loves this. No, they all do the show. The timing just didn't work out with the road, but I was so honored. You guys are all the funniest people ever. Everyone I know loves this. No, they all love the show. I know nobody likes compliments, but I love the show. They love the show. I saw you at our mutual friend, Jane's house. Yes. And sweet Jane Buffett.
你们都是最有趣的人。我认识的每个人都喜欢这个。不，他们都做这个节目。时间安排和巡演冲突了，但我感到非常荣幸。你们都是最有趣的人。我认识的每个人都喜欢这个。不，他们都喜欢这个节目。我知道没人喜欢恭维，但我喜欢这个节目。他们喜欢这个节目。我在我们共同的朋友简家里见过你。是的。还有可爱的简·巴菲特。
Sweet sweet Jane. And we talked about it, and then I inquired, and then it didn't work out timing-wise and then I see you pop up today and it's taken me most of the show to recover from that. It's the equivalent of being slapped in the face with an empty glove. Is it?
可爱的简。我们谈过这件事，然后我打听了一下，结果时间上没凑巧，然后今天看到你出现，我花了节目大部分时间才从中恢复过来。这相当于被一只空手套扇了一巴掌。是吗？
Yeah. Wow. An empty glove. Yeah, and you know what I mean? And I always, I know I have very sort of old fashioned, you know, images, but anyway, I'm now over it. And I'm just glad you're here. Very royal metaphors.
是的。哇。一只空手套。是的，你知道我的意思吗？我总是，我知道我有一些老派的，你知道，形象，但无论如何，我现在已经过去了。我很高兴你在这里。非常皇室的隐喻。
I am, I am very regal. You didn't ask me about my lineage and I didn't want to do it because I don't want to sit here and fucking make everybody feel bad. Oh my God, are you okay? Canadian royalty. No, what's going on? Are you descended from somebody?
我是，我非常尊贵。你没问我的血统，我也不想说，因为我不想坐在这里让每个人都感觉不好。天哪，你还好吗？加拿大皇室。不，怎么了？你是谁的后代吗？
Wow. Yeah, maybe. Wayne G? Are you descended from somebody? Wow. Yeah, maybe. Wayne Gretzky? Wayne Gretzky. Amy, all the accomplishments you've had and everything that you've succeeded in all of these years, is there something you haven't reached yet? Is there something you'd like to bury right now
哇。是的，也许吧。韦恩·格雷茨基？你是谁的后代吗？哇。是的，也许吧。韦恩·格雷茨基？韦恩·格雷茨基。艾米，你这些年来取得的所有成就和成功，有什么是你还没达到的吗？有什么你想现在埋葬的吗
from your high position? My uterus. Oh, for fuck's sake. I'm sorry, I'm having fun. I swear to you that it never offended me for one second, but the idea that you think that maybe it offended me is like, you know, it makes me feel good. Well, I don't, you know, we play around,
从你的高位？我的子宫。哦，去你的。抱歉，我玩得很开心。我向你发誓，它从来没有冒犯过我一秒钟，但你认为它可能冒犯了我，这让我感觉很好。嗯，我不知道，你知道，我们只是开玩笑，
but you never ever really want to actually hurt anybody's feelings. I can really barely manage having one, and I cannot imagine if it had worked out to have another one. And I don't miss my uterus, and I cannot imagine if it had worked out to have another one. And I don't miss my uterus, and I still have my ovaries, so I'm not in menopause. Okay. Yeah.
但你永远不想真正伤害任何人的感情。我几乎无法应付生一个，我无法想象如果我成功生了另一个会怎样。我不怀念我的子宫，我无法想象如果我成功生了另一个会怎样。我不怀念我的子宫，而且我还有卵巢，所以我还没进入更年期。好的。是的。
Huh. Well, hang on, they're going my next five. Ha ha ha ha. Ha ha ha ha. Ha ha ha ha. I tapped out, I'm tapped. Speaking of tapped out, we are past the one hour mark, and that's our commitment to you, our guest. You only have to give us an hour
嗯。好吧，等等，他们要我接下来的五分钟。哈哈哈哈。哈哈哈哈。哈哈哈哈。我认输了，我累了。说到累了，我们已经超过一小时了，这是我们对你，我们的客人的承诺。你只需要给我们一个小时
and we love you and already miss you. Amy? Yes. Am I canceled after this bad guest? No, I am. Again. Did you get canceled once before? Many times. I've been canceled many times.
我们爱你，已经开始想你了。艾米？是的。在这个糟糕的客人之后我被取消了吗？不，是我。又来了。你之前被取消过一次吗？很多次。我被取消过很多次。
Truly? Of course. You've said some controversial things. I don't even think. What was the first time we met, Amy? Do you remember? The very first time? Yeah.
真的吗？当然。你说过一些有争议的话。我甚至不认为。我们第一次见面是什么时候，艾米？你记得吗？第一次？是的。
Was it at James? This is where feelings get hard. Oh no, we met at Kimmel's. No, and that's why I'm asking you this. Cause we'd met before and at Kimmel's, this is why I'm burning you, cause you burned me back then. We had met before and you and I were talking to Conan
是在吉米家吗？这就是感情变得困难的地方。哦不，我们在吉米·坎摩尔的节目上见面的。不，这就是我问你的原因。因为我们之前见过面，在吉米家，这就是我为什么损你，因为你当时也损我。我们之前见过面，你和我正在和柯南说话
and I said, hey, blah, blah, blah, and you go, we fucking met like six months ago and I go, sorry, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. And now you think- I hate when people do that. And now you think that that was the first time you met. I did not. No, did I really do that?
我说，嘿，巴拉巴拉，你说，我们六个月前就见过了，我说，抱歉，巴拉巴拉。现在你认为——我讨厌人们那样做。现在你认为那是你们第一次见面。我没有。不，我真的那样做了吗？
I hate when people do that. I mean, you weren't shitty. You were in shitty. We were laughing, but- You and I met first time we met at, was it Kimmel's? I think it was Kimmel's. Yeah. It was that same time.
我讨厌人们那样做。我的意思是，你并不糟糕。你并不糟糕。我们在笑，但是——你和我第一次见面是在，是在吉米家吗？我想是在吉米家。是的。就是那次。
It was that same time at Kimmel's. Yeah, that was. Amy, do you remember the first time we met? Today. It was today. It was today. On this, on this pod. Okay, I know we're wrapping up,
就是那次在吉米家。是的，那是。艾米，你记得我们第一次见面吗？今天。是今天。是今天。在这个播客上。好吧，我知道我们要结束了，
but really can you just tell me, I don't, I really think. Oh no, we laugh. I don't, we now we both don't remember the actual first time. Maybe I was just messing with you. Oh, maybe you were. It's okay.'t remember the actual first time. Maybe I was just messing with you. Maybe you were. It's okay. The first time Will and I met, I don't remember. I told him one day after I'd stopped drinking for a while.
但真的你能告诉我吗，我真的认为。哦不，我们笑。我们现在都不记得真正第一次见面是什么时候了。也许我只是在逗你。哦，也许你是。没关系。我和威尔第一次见面，我不记得了。我戒酒一段时间后有一天告诉他。
Or no, it was after you would stop drinking. Will stopped drinking before me. I think I said something until like, boy, our timing's terrible. I would've loved to just get slammed with you. You know, we're great if we'd parted together. And he said, oh no, we have. We did.
或者不，是在你戒酒之后。威尔在我之前戒酒了。我想我说了一些类似的话，天哪，我们的时间太糟糕了。我本来很想和你一起喝个烂醉。你知道，如果我们一起聚会会很棒。他说，哦不，我们有过。我们有过。
Oh. We had like eight years, six, seven, eight years before we had gone out one night. And I went ahead and got a little over-served. Oh my gosh. Didn't. Oh, you know who I have to say this before I forget is that I work with someone that you both work with.
哦。我们在某天晚上出去之前大概有八年，六、七、八年的时间。我继续喝多了。哦天哪。没有。哦，在你忘记之前我必须说的是，我和你们俩都共事过的人一起工作。
Uh-oh. Do you remember Michael Sarah? Michael Sarah, that's right. And we have our second season of our TV show, Life and Beth on Hulu. Yes. That people should watch. On Hulu, with Michael Sarah that you can watch right now.
哦哦。你记得迈克尔·塞拉吗？迈克尔·塞拉，没错。我们有我们的电视剧《生活与贝丝》的第二季，在Hulu上。是的。人们应该看看。在Hulu上，和迈克尔·塞拉一起，你现在就可以看。
Just go to Hulu and watch it. Watch it, like what's your problem problem that you're not watching it? Michael, Sarah. Let's do a watch party. A little lover. Love it, Michael, Sarah. He's a little lover. Amy Schumer, so funny, so talented.
去Hulu看吧。看吧，你不看它有什么问题吗？迈克尔·塞拉。我们来办个观看派对吧。小爱人。喜欢它，迈克尔·塞拉。他是个小爱人。艾米·舒默，太有趣了，太有才华了。
You're the greatest. Yeah, you're great. Oh, God, I'm very nice. In your handsome house back there. Yeah. Wait, I just want to show you the stuffed animal before it's over. OK, I want to see the haunted toys.
你是最棒的。是的，你很棒。哦，天哪，我很好。在你后面那栋漂亮的房子里。是的。等等，在结束之前我只想给你看那个毛绒玩具。好的，我想看看那些闹鬼的玩具。
This is my real stuffed animal. This is my real stuffed animal. Oh, my God. Oh, listener. This is like a stuffed panda bear that looks like it got dragged behind a pickup truck. That is the scariest. It's not even a pig.
这是我真正的毛绒玩具。这是我真正的毛绒玩具。哦，天哪。哦，听众们。这就像一只毛绒熊猫，看起来像是被皮卡车拖过一样。那是最可怕的。它甚至不是一只猪。
It's not a joke. Like, this is my actual stuffed animal from growing up. Does it look like that because when you're angry, that's where you take it out? Did your parents hate you? This was my mom's when she was a little girl. Yeah. And did she have claws?
这不是开玩笑。这是我从小到大的毛绒玩具。它看起来那样是因为当你生气时，你就拿它出气吗？你父母讨厌你吗？这是我妈妈小时候的。是的。它有爪子吗？
It's like a hundred years, like filled with straw. I don't know, all my stuffed animals. I like like old antique stuff down. I don't know. It's something that I have. It's like show me on the doll where't know all my stuffed animals. I like like old antique stuff down. I don't know. It's something's out. It's like show me on the doll where he touched you and it's just like everywhere. Oh my God.
它有一百岁了，里面塞满了稻草。我不知道，我所有的毛绒玩具。我喜欢旧的古董东西。我不知道。这是我有的东西。就像在娃娃身上指出他摸了你哪里，到处都是。哦，天哪。
Feathers everywhere. Oh my God. My God. Amy, love you. Love you. Love you, Amy. See you soon, I think. I hope.
到处都是羽毛。哦，天哪。天哪。艾米，爱你。爱你。爱你，艾米。我想很快会再见。我希望。
Amy Schumer. The one, the only. The only. Okay. All right. And also go on blue apron and get an apron, right? Wait, no, that's not what they sell at Blue Apron. Get, if you want an apron, make it blue.
艾米·舒默。独一无二的。唯一的。好的。好的。还有去Blue Apron买个围裙，对吧？等等，不，那不是他们在Blue Apron卖的东西。如果你想要围裙，买蓝色的。
Get the blue one, strap it on and cook. Don't strap anything on, nobody's, no. All right, bye. Bye, thank you, thank you, thank you. That's Amy Schumer, everybody. That's Amy Schumer, everybody. Wow, I've always wanted to meet her in there. She's the greatest.
买蓝色的，系上它然后做饭。什么都别系，没人，不。好的，再见。再见，谢谢，谢谢，谢谢。那是艾米·舒默，各位。那是艾米·舒默，各位。哇，我一直想在那里见到她。她是最好的。
I mean, you sit down and start talking to her like you've known her for 45 years. I've always been a fan of hers ever since she came on. She, I remember her, the first time I think I saw her was on Ellen and the Ellen DeGeneres show. And she, she just was naturally funny, would tell story. And everybody was dying, laughing like, who is this girl? How does she have the confidence?
我的意思是，你坐下来开始和她说话，就像你认识她45年了一样。我一直都是她的粉丝，自从她出道以来。我记得她，我想我第一次见到她是在艾伦·德杰尼勒斯的节目上。她，她天生就很有趣，会讲故事。每个人都笑得要死，心想，这女孩是谁？她怎么有这种自信？
She's really smart. She's smart and confident. Yeah, and the boss just kind of say whatever she thinks and feels. And you know, there was a, this is known, this is public. She was gonna be Barbie. There was gonna be a version, they were gonna be Barbie movie with her. That's right.
她真的很聪明。她聪明又自信。是的，老板只是说出她想到的和感受到的。你知道，有一个，这是众所周知的，这是公开的。她本来要演芭比。本来有一个版本，本来要拍一部有她的芭比电影。没错。
And I was so excited about that. I mean, obviously the Marco Robbie one is incredible and congratulations to all their success on that. But I will always be curious what her version would have been. Sequel. Yeah, just her sensibility and her approach and the irony of playing that sort of iconic,
我对此感到非常兴奋。我的意思是，显然玛格特·罗比的版本令人难以置信，祝贺他们在那方面取得的所有成功。但我永远会好奇她的版本会是什么样。续集。是的，只是她的感性、她的方法以及扮演那种标志性的、
glam part would have been pretty cool and smart, I'll bet. Yeah. Anyway. Well, I never say never. Never say never, right? I'm sure there'll probably be at least two or three more Barbies, you know? Yeah, for sure. she should get in there
迷人的角色的讽刺意味会很酷很聪明，我敢打赌。是的。无论如何。好吧，我从不说绝不。从不说绝不，对吧？我相信可能还会有至少两三部芭比电影，你知道吗？是的，肯定的。她应该加入进去
Sure, she should be one of the Barbies. Yeah Any parts that you guys decided not to do that other people did and that you're like, oh, I could have done that or that people Might not know that you passed up. Oh Yeah, I mean the the famous one that you guys know that always bring up which is You know, it's not that big of a role, but it was Madagascar, the giraffe in Madagascar. You were gonna do it in the chronic role. I pass.
当然，她应该是芭比娃娃之一。是的，你们决定不做而别人做了，然后你们觉得，哦，我本来可以做那个，或者人们可能不知道你们放弃了的角色吗？哦，是的，我的意思是你们都知道的那个著名的角色，总是被提起，就是，你知道，那不是什么大角色，但那是《马达加斯加》，《马达加斯加》里的长颈鹿。你本来要演那个角色。我放弃了。
I know that the audience is. Who ended up doing that voice? David Schwimmer did a wonderful job at playing that. Did you just not see a way into that character, Sean? Is that one? No, it was, I don't know why. I was actually advised to pass because it was, they didn't have a script or anything. Who is that? So my manager at the time was like I don't know why. I was actually advised to pass because they didn't have a script or anything.
我知道观众是。最后是谁配了那个音？大卫·休默在扮演那个角色方面做得非常出色。肖恩，你只是没看出那个角色的门道吗？是那个吗？不，是，我不知道为什么。我实际上被建议放弃，因为，他们当时没有剧本什么的。那是谁？所以当时的经纪人就像，我不知道为什么。我实际上被建议放弃，因为他们没有剧本什么的。
Who would pass you? My manager at the time was like, don't do it. I was like, really? Okay. So I didn't do it. And then they made like five of them or something. Yeah. Well, did you-
谁会让你放弃？当时的经纪人就像，别做。我当时想，真的吗？好的。所以我没做。然后他们拍了大概五部还是什么的。是的。好吧，你——
You would have made so much money from that. Well, it would have been fun. Did your agent pass- Oh, you would have made so much money. Oh, okay, fine. Did your agent pass on it for you or did you call the director personally and just say, yeah, you know what?
你本来可以从中赚很多钱的。好吧，那本来会很有趣。你的经纪人帮你放弃了——哦，你本来可以赚很多钱的。哦，好吧，没关系。你的经纪人帮你放弃了，还是你亲自给导演打电话说，是的，你知道吗？
Bye. God. Bye. Does that work? Let's go. Smart. What? Smart.
再见。天哪。再见。那样管用吗？我们走吧。聪明。什么？聪明。
What? Smart. What? Smart. What? Smart. What? What?
什么？聪明。什么？聪明。什么？聪明。什么？什么？
What? What? Smart. Lass. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjalf, and Bennett Barbaco. Smart. Lass. If you like smart lists, you can listen early and add free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple podcasts. Prime members can listen ad free on Amazon Music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wondry.com slash survey. Hey, listener, it's Sean Hayes. Do you know when Crystal Pepsi was discontinued or what was in Al Capone's vault?
什么？什么？聪明。SmartLess。SmartLess是100%有机的，由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿姆贾尔夫和贝内特·巴巴科手工制作。SmartLess。如果你喜欢SmartLess，你可以通过在Wondry应用程序或Apple播客上加入Wondry Plus来立即收听无广告的提前内容。Prime会员可以在Amazon Music上收听无广告内容。在你离开之前，通过在Wondry.com/survey填写简短调查告诉我们关于你的信息。嘿，听众们，我是肖恩·海耶斯。你知道水晶百事可乐是什么时候停产的，或者阿尔·卡彭的保险库里有什么吗？
If not, then you haven't spent enough time on Wikipedia. But that's okay because you can learn all about it on the new podcast, Wiki Hole, from all of us here at SmartList Media. Discover the craziest rabbit holes on Wikipedia with host Darcy Cardin and her favorite comedian friends as they bring the cyber frontier directly to your tympanic membrane. And if you listen to WikiHole, you'd learn that's the science term for eardrum. WikiHole is the wild, wild west of Wikipedia.
如果没有，那你花在维基百科上的时间还不够多。但没关系，因为你可以在SmartLess Media的我们所有人制作的新播客《Wiki Hole》中了解这一切。与主持人达西·卡登和她最喜欢的喜剧演员朋友一起探索维基百科上最疯狂的兔子洞，他们将网络前沿直接带到你的鼓膜。如果你听了《Wiki Hole》，你就会知道那是耳膜的科学术语。《Wiki Hole》是维基百科的狂野西部。
Starting out on one Wikipedia page, they go from link to link to link to link, careening through trivia, oddities, and unexpected connections until everyone wonders, how the hell did we get here? Follow WikiHole on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcast. You can listen to Wicked Hole ad free by joining Wondery Plus
从一个维基百科页面开始，他们从链接到链接，在琐事、奇闻和意想不到的联系中穿梭，直到每个人都想知道，我们到底是怎么到这里的？在Wondry应用程序或任何你获取播客的地方关注《Wiki Hole》。你可以通过加入Wondry Plus来收听无广告的《Wiki Hole》
in the Wondery app or on Apple podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在Wondry应用程序或Apple播客上。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。